pour tous les plus grands tournois
d'échec il se déroulent en présentiel ou
en ligne vivez comprenez en direct les
parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats des comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chains.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
et salut tout salut à tous bonjour à
tous huitième ronde bonjour à tous salut
Fatou et bonjour le chat salut à tous
j'espère que vous allez très très bien
et aujourd'hui effectivement on va
commenter ensemble la ronde 8 du
Nord-Ouest qui va commencer dans un
instant on pense donc 17h pile on voit
que Carlson n'est pas encore arrivé vous
voyez qu'il y a des caméras sur les
joueurs
on voit qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est à
côté de ma média off je pense que c'est
un officier tu as peut-être vouloir
jouer le premier coup même à dire où
l'on peut aller voir sur la la grande
caméra
oups c'était pas celle-là
voilà alors est-ce que
est-ce que
on va avoir cette dame et son sac à main
à côté qui va nous c'est une dame je
crois
qui va nous jouer le premier coup de
chaque
erreur ma meilleure offre
je pense que c'est Descartes le coup
salut à tous salut
Kilian sur sur Youtube bienvenue à tous
bienvenue
et salut à tous ceux qui sont sur
Youtube aussi
ça change on voit que la partie n'a pas
encore commencé oui et là elle va jouer
un coup et elle va jouer des quatre aïe
aïe aïe aïe
des deux mais il va quand même rejet des
4 c'était pas une surprise
si je joue pas des quatre Fatou
et des cas évidemment
que ça notre ami diarraf
alors c'est un joueur qui aime beaucoup
attaquer il adore tout envoyer
il balance du HK G4 dans toutes ces
parties
avec les Blancs contre 45 et ben écoute
c'est c'est intéressant parce que
Carlson bien sûr il avait noir rencontre
mais c'est un joueur qui qui veut la
coller à 45 c'est pas un joueur du style
pleutre et à attendre de faire nul donc
on peut avoir ici une partie je pense
assez intéressantes enfin tout
j'imagine bien aussi un peu peut-être
comme hier d'ailleurs une partie où on
essaye de de surprendre et de balancer
ouais hier c'était enfin hier c'était
avant-hier
mais il y a deux jours voilà c'était la
partie
beaucoup beaucoup de surprises des deux
côtés c'était assez drôle enfin tout on
peut essayer une une nouvelle vue juste
cette vue là
où on va voir en fait toutes les parties
sauf que là on voit encore que les
apparemment sont mal mis ou un Magnus
4500 et c'est pas du tout la
pareillement on va revenir à notre vue
plus normal
donc pour l'instant est à jour elle est
pas mal pour suivre un petit peu de tout
le monde
dans la oui oui mais bon malheureusement
ça a marché que la premier jour et
ça marche plus et salut thé vert
bienvenue à toi
il va se
mais il est avec nous oui
alors
est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour on va un
peu ce qui se passe cette position pour
l'instant mais écoute c'est une sorte de
de gambidables assistantes
C5 C6 un truc comme ça
c'est très très standard tout ça ah il
est au taf c'est caché pour me jeter un
agréable stream fais gaffe à ta chef tu
es vraiment j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était pas tout le temps facile
la duchesse la duchesse ouais il paraît
qu'elle aime pas trop te voir faire du
Bullet pendant que tu travailles et en
vrai moi je changerai le boss
si c'était le cas
enfin toi tu as pas de boss c'était
mieux oui j'en ai pas
alors hop la deuxième partie qu'on va
avoir ici c'est la partie d'Ali resa
contre Aniche Guiri donc là c'est une
ouverture alors ça c'est bizarre
parce que ça commence ça regarde ça a
commencé avec E4 Fatou E5 cavalier F3 ca
va laisser 6 et G3
est-ce que tu connais ça est-ce que tu
as déjà vu ça Fatou
j'ai déjà joué ça
va pouvoir tout nous expliquer alors
toutes les idées
de cette ouverture ah dommage
bah en fait moi ce que je peux dire de
ça c'est qu'en fait et ben les Blancs
jouent une sorte d'est indienne
au final
et mais bon c'est vrai que c'est quand
même assez bizarre
généralement toujours pas trop ça sur E4
c'est vrai que là il y a le foot à 5
mais bon ça ça a déjà été joué mais bon
tire déjà l'optique je pense deux
surprendre qui est extrêmement bien
préparé il veut une position qui joue où
il y a pas beaucoup de prépa donc
objectif voilà salut madame
salut malin alors troisième table nous
avons Nakamura contre Abdou satorov ab12
avec les Blancs contre Nakamura plutôt
dans cet endroit là et donc ça commence
avec une
Espagnole Fatou qui est extrêmement
connu cavalier 4 tours
et ces positions et ben elles sont
extrêmement égalisantes
on le voit s'ajoute très très vite natel
qui nous il y a peut-être nous refaire
comme avant-hier
petite récitation de de théorie ouais
après Abdou c'est pas le genre à faire
une turbodro
c'est pas du tout le genre
donc bon même si la position il arrive
pas forcément à obtenir grand chose on
va voir et ben c'est pas le genre à
faire un turbo de rose un genre qui qui
veut essayer de bien jouer qui veut
essayer de gagner mettre la pression
donc là tu verras pas tu verras pas une
turboie ça c'est
pour nous
[Musique]
l'idée B3 c'est j'imagine le coup que
Nakamura veut essayer de créer pour
ouvrir la colonne adverse toujours qui
avait les bêtises des 5 et tu as une
structure un petit peu comme une
Française échange toi c'est une
structure assez solide pour les noirs et
puis bon on va voir un petit peu comment
ça se passe donc je vois pas vraiment
ma caméra perd cette partie pour
l'instant je sais pas avoir la suite
4 on a goût cache avec les Blancs contre
Ariane tari et il commence avec
Fatou un petit système de Londres
et est-ce que sa tête ça te va un petit
peu la couverture
est-ce que tu es étonné de voir moi je
le suis ouais moi aussi
ben oui surtout que bon c'est un système
qui est extrêmement solide et puis la
gogash avec les Blancs veut mettre la
pression Atari après on l'a déjà vu des
joueurs qui veulent mettre la pression à
leur adversaire en jouant justement cet
homme de Londres c'est déjà vu parce que
nous en fait à notre niveau
ou plus amateur on voit le système de
Londres comme une ouverture qui est qui
est parfaite pour le débutant parce que
c'est toujours même schéma c'est très
facile à jouer etc on se prend pas la
tête et souvent aussi c'est une artère
que tu fais des fois quand tu es un peu
moins fort et que tu veux essayer de
faire nul tu vois un truc hyper solide
bon alors que là on le rappelle quand
même tarif c'est le petit poucet de la
compétition donc c'est pas personne
essayait vraiment de faire une contre
lui on veut on veut le battre on veut
s'imposer et en plus si
c'est lui qui termine le classement
donc je pense que l'objectif c'est c'est
toujours de gagner contre lui c'est ça
donc mais après le choix d'ouverture de
vos caches bah il a pas de ça pour
pour faire nul clairement pas il veut
gagner il veut mettre des points
et il a sûrement avoir une idée dans
cette partie et peut-être aussi encore
une fois ce que Nakamura disait lors
d'une de ses parties après dans une
interview il avait dit que
ça stratégie souvent c'est de faire
durer la partie pour pour flaguer en
gros et bon Google je suis c'est un
jeune qui veut essayer de bien José
chèques
les pas un jeune qui veut jouer vite
pour flag d'accord c'est pas le même
style que Naka et mais bon il a joué ça
il a sûrement une idée derrière la tête
de comment il faut jouer
cette position donc je suis en bétonné
mais bon on va voir un petit peu comment
comment la partie va se jouer et la
dernière partie Fatou c'est les deux
joueurs
américains kerwana contre so Wesley
qui sont en tête du classement alors le
classement d'ailleurs on peut le montrer
donc on a enfin le deuxième tournoi
c'est pas souvent c'est Nakamura je
crois mais on va pouvoir
on avait les trois Américains qui
étaient en tête et ça c'est
et alors rapidement
donc
ces joueurs qui sont joués un milliard
de fois chacun
fout des 6 et ici il y a plusieurs
plantes pour les Noirs généralement ce
qu'on sait de faire c'est plutôt de
jouer avec C5
mais est-ce que un coup comme fou assise
Fatou peut être possible pour pour
échanger les fous sachant que le fou
c'est 8 c'est mon mauvais fou et que le
fouet 3 c'est le bon fou des blancs
exactement donc c'est carrément possible
mais ouais ben lui il est rouge un
parent
donc x 6 serait une possibilité
après
de la couleur dans vos parties
identifier votre bonne pièce vos
mauvaises pièces
amenez vos post-it en tournoi IRL
n'hésitez pas vous prenez des feutres
sinon
mais après attention que si vous prenez
des feutres et ben une mauvaise pièce
pour devenir bonne donc des fois ça peut
être un peu compliqué mais le post-it
donc là ok écoute
on prépare un peu tout mais sinon après
il faut aussi il faut assise et c'est 5
on postule pour préparer aussi la
poussée et on peut aussi que des fois
quand l'eau c'est 5 et on a envie que le
centre plus tard soit solide et
éventuellement ouvert en fait si tu veux
jouer avec ces cinq le foot tu mettras
pas un racisme pourquoi parce qu'en
jouant avec ces cinq je parle tout seul
je vous fais des mêmes questions à moi
tout seul tu vois et ben sur ces cinq
sixième tu prends en C5
et ben ah oui
il faut se parler tout seul des fois moi
ça m'arrive ça m'arrive souvent de
parler tout seul et après prendre des
prends et ben ce qui se passe c'est
qu'on a des pions pendant
et les pions pendant c'est les pions qui
sont
qui sont sur des colonnes semi-ouvertes
et qui peuvent être à la fois faibles et
forts donc son force on arrive à le
dynamique il y a les pousser un jour et
créer un pion passé sinon attention que
les pions plus tard peuvent être faibles
s'ils sont attaqués par les pions par
les pièces et du coup ce qui est logique
c'est que ces pions pendant vous ne
favorisez si on est actif donc qui y
a-t-il dit avoir plein de pièces donc si
je fais C5 prise pour je foi 6 et ben
j'ai rien compris parce que je vais
changer des pièces et il ne faut pas
échanger des pièces quand on a
des pions qui sont potentiellement
faibles comme ici
donc voilà essayez de garder vos pièces
si vous jouez une structure du style
pion pendant ou plus on isolés jouer
actif jolie initiative par exemple full
à cavalier là un truc comme ça jouer
actif vraiment
et par contre si vous voulez je sais 5
et ben j'imagine que la suite de la
partie sera pas forcément accessante ce
sera plus par exemple dans le style plus
tard de jouer
ces 6 et de solide quoi donc avoir en
tout cas c'est mon avis je suis pas un
expert de ces positions mais la
structure par contre je la connais
ah oui c'est beau ce que tu dis salut
on sent le côté prof
surtout mettre des couleurs enfin tout
ça c'est important
très important sauf pour les daltoniens
je vous présente toutes nos excuses
ouais parce que Fatou et ben je vous
l'expliquer le fait de mettre des
couleurs c'est vrai que
un petit un petit conseil que je
pourrais vous donner en tout cas dans le
chat quand vous jouez une partie essayez
de toujours penser à vos bonnes pièces
oui il a fait le coup passe partout
pensez à vos à vos pièces et essayer de
mettre des couleurs sur la pièce pour
savoir qui est bon qui est pas bon et
qu'elle va être l'enjeu de la partie
parement pluie c'est un bon cavalier lui
c'est un bon cavalier lui c'est le bon
fou parce qu'il a couleur inverse des
pions du centre et lui c'est un fou qui
est théoriquement pas très bon parce
qu'il est de la même couleur que les
pions du centre à l'inverse on voit que
lui il est pas mal lui il est pas mal
lui
fasse mes trucs je vais revenir en
arrière voilà
le cavalier en B8 qui est pas sorti mais
quand il sortira il aura des gaz normal
et le fou c'est 8 c'est dans la théorie
de mauvais fou parce que j'ai un pion
blanc en dessin quand on lui centre donc
après
vu la production c'est pas forcément si
grave encore une fois si je sais 5 et
que les pions s'échangent m'en fous va
venir en B7 il aura quand même une
diagonale sympa mais j'ai des pions qui
seront plus faibles mais en tout cas
dans la théorie le pion enfin de fou je
le mets en rouge et quand on connaît
enfin quand on fait on va dire un peu
dans notre tête ces couleurs là et ben
on se rend compte qu'avec les Noirs par
exemple ce fou va nous fait défaut mais
si on arrive à échanger contre le fou
vert de l'adversaire ben après j'aurais
que des pièces vertes c'est à dire
j'aurais que des bonnes pièces et
l'adversaire aura une mauvaise pièce en
rouge vous voyez c'est un peu un truc
comme ça et bien sûr dans l'inverse les
des blondes avaient essayé de
éventuellement d'améliorer ce fou des
deux ou d'échanger ça c'est une
stratégie qui est intéressante
et quand vous savez pas quoi faire en
partie essayez souvent d'améliorer vos
pièces ça c'est la clé et ce que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens ne savent pas
je pense à une question Fatou on a pu
voir très très souvent c'est je sais pas
quoi faire exactement c'est souvent les
débutants quand ils sortent de
l'ouverture donc ils ont bien appris et
respectent bien les principes
d'ouverture et puis une fois terminé on
a sorti les pièces on a pris le centre
on a rocket bah qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon
c'est plus donc il faut trouver des
idées il faut avoir un plan et pour ça
bah il faut se poser des questions et se
poser des questions comme le dit
Stéphane sur sur notamment ces pièces
quelles sont les bonnes ou les mauvaises
les échanges qu'on va pouvoir faire les
cibles adverses aussi les faiblesses
adverses donc il y a plein plein de
questions qu'on peut se poser quand on
est débutant
et après qui vont devenir mécanique par
exemple je souffle à toutes les couleurs
dans sa tête il y a pas besoin de les
faire sur les fichiers parce qu'il s'est
posé tellement de fois les questions que
maintenant il sait tout
après des fois on se trompe aussi un des
fois vous avez la pièce qui est
théoriquement forte faible qui en fait
n'est pas si bonne fin bref vous savez
en fait des fois il y a des exceptions
mais après la théorie de base
de ça on la connaît mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de gens des fois et ben soit en
partie et ne savent pas quoi faire dans
certaines positions et on dit ouais je
connais pas la position où je sais pas
juste pas besoin vous inquiétez pas on
va essayer de comprendre ensemble et du
coup déterminer vous-même la force de
vos pièces et ce qu'il faut essayer de
faire
donc tout re 8 c'est un coup que j'aime
bien parce que c'est très flexible en
fait
c'est un coup qui contrôle le centre qui
empêche le 4 oui le 4 c'est un coup qui
était possible pour les blancs avant
parce que ça permet d'ouvrir ce fou qui
était mauvais bon après j'ai un plan
isolé mais ça permet de l'ouvrir pas mal
de choses et même plus tard par comme 4
c'est un aussi éventuellement d'ouvrir
cette diagonale sur blanc éventuellement
je remette un fou mais dans l'idée de
tout revu ça empêche le 4 ça contrôle la
cage de 4 donc éventuellement un jour
faire qu'à la ligne 4 c'est une
possibilité
mais je me presse pas à savoir si je
bouge lui si je bouge l'eau si je bouge
le en fait si je bouge je m'en fous a
priori je pourrais plus faire forêt
parce que je peux faire ça pourra pas
faire ça enfin ça n'a pas de sens ou
faire ça pour après ouais ça a pas de
sens pour un prêt par rapport à venir là
si je bouge mon cavalier je pourrais
plus faire fois si non plus parce que le
cavalier pourra plus défendre ce fou
et si je fais ces cinq et ben comment on
l'a dit avant on n'aura plus envie
d'échanger les fous donc en fait il veut
pas se commit à jouer un coup ou l'autre
il va voir un petit peu ce que font les
blancs et en fonction ce que font les
blancs choisir
sa manière de jouer quoi donc tout remix
m'a l'air assez souple tu gardes un
petit peu toutes les possibilités
mais gardez le pion C en pion arrière en
ne jouant pas S5 c'est pas terrible non
plus alors oui c'est sûr chaboudou mais
bon mon pion je peux toujours le pousser
à ce moment je peux toujours faire ça ou
ça donc à un moment donné il va se
passer quelque chose généralement c'est
5 c'est un coup quand même dans sa
position que je viens par jouer
d'ailleurs une idée c'est un de ces
quatre c'est on a déjà parlé pas mal de
cette structure là lors de nos streams
là dans watchesse avec une
éventuelle
majorité de trois contre deux ici si
j'arrive à le C4 donc ça reste toujours
une possibilité mais je suis pas pressé
de le faire en fait et j'imagine que les
Noirs veulent attendre de voir ce que
font les blancs parce que là les blancs
ils doivent prendre ici maintenant
est-ce que je
joue taureau je sais pas
sur
ouais moi
et après chasses tu pousses comme ça
mais si tu chantes à plus facile tu as
vu oups
donc
c'est clair
après je peux aussi faire que ça sonne
direct mais généralement ce fou on ne
donne pas c'est le bon fou
ça fait mal au cœur de le donner
et
là on peut imaginer il y a plusieurs
coups qu'on peut regarder
a pas trop je pense qu'elle va les
prendre des 5 à l'art intéressant je
suis pas trop fan de faire froid je veux
en fait de cette position même si je
récupère là j'ai quand même perdu ma
paire de fou tu sais à quel point j'aime
les fous ouais je le sais question
encore dans cette partie j'aimerais bien
les garder aussi
et
je rigole
quel est le cas du coup c'est pas c'est
pas j'aime pas trop mais tu as encore
l'idée de fois 6 ou de ce5 là il va
joindre des deux j'utilise mais
[Musique]
non je pense un fou assez simple je
dirais un des deux pas tout
et je crois qu'on a fait le tour de nos
parties
donc pour l'instant c'est le début de
partie se passe pas grand grand grand
chose on a encore dans le début
et je suis un petit peu surpris quand
même par le choix de Google je comprends
trop tard rien cette cette système de
Londres alors si on revient sur 47
ouais ouais alors que s'est-il passé
exactement cette partie t'arrêter là
c'est 5 donc c'est une sorte structure
d'arrache
prise vous prend à 3 cavaler ses 6 prise
qui va les prendre et là il joue Campion
isolé
avec un pion isolé mais je vous rappelle
qu'il faut jouer actif quand on a un
pion isolé il faut prendre et d'un mecs
qui attaque ici le pion
B2 alors une idée noire
ça va être très vite de jouer des cartes
c'est tout
alors je sais pas comment il va le faire
comment il va s'y prendre
du type là il faut défendre le pion
alors défendant
comment défensions est-ce qu'on joint
dame 2 est-ce qu'on joue autour B1
est-ce qu'on joue B4
dames C2 aussi est un coup mais je suis
pas fan de laisser madame sur les
colonnes sommet ouverte un jour je sens
que je vais devoir bouger madame c'est
par exemple un truc comme ça j'ai peur
d'un truc comme ça
j'ai peur sur le terme donc un truc
comme ça celui un truc comme ça
et je me demande si c'est pas
là je faisais 6 je pense sur case noire
et après c'est de faire des cadres
là par exemple des cartes
parce que
là c'est égal
tu es content
parce qu'en fait moi je pensais à je D4
mais ici il y a un petit piège il y a un
petit piège prise
boum boum boum vous voyez la découverte
échec sur la dame donc ça ça va pas du
tout alors par contre Descartes ça reste
quand même une possibilité
des fois Fatou en sacrifiant le pion
pour jetons des 8
et le prendre rapidement mais bon
tourner si tu continues à apprendre et
bien il y aura toujours faut prendre un
J7 à la fin mais bon peut-être j'ai
fougé 4
tranquillement quoi
mais alors c'est position les Noirs
arrivent à égaliser donc est-ce que
Carlsen va réussir
à jouer des cadres alors je sais pas
comment soit il joue ça soit il joue ça
pour jouer ça soit il joue ça pour je
vous les deux quoi mais le jeu Magnus va
se baser sur la poussée du pion des 4 et
se libérer de cette faiblesse de pions
isolé et une fois que ça fait et ben la
position sera égale et sera
peut-être bientôt nul j'ai envie de dire
Fatou
et les blancs doivent essayer de lutter
pour ne pas que les Noirs fassent ça
donc mais là j'ai pas eu le temps
j'avais pu en prise mais par exemple si
jamais je fais un mauvais coup peut-être
venir bloquer le pur isolé ça c'est ce
qu'on doit faire généralement
on empêche de pousser comme ça on garde
la faiblesse chez le noir et puis après
on l'attaque et on l'a détruit si
possible au fur et à mesure on va la
bloquer on va l'attaquer avec nos pièces
etc et après même Fatou elle sait
qu'après si on n'arrive pas à manger le
pion il faut créer ce qu'on appelle la
deuxième faiblesse
mais
donc normalement Magnus devrait essayer
de réagir vite au centre
pour éliminer cette potentiel faiblesse
depuis on les avait donc là il faut voir
concrètement est-ce que je peux jouer 4
est-ce que je peux le jouer
si je prends du pion bon on a dit que ça
c'était pas possible
est-ce que je peux jouer ça
là je menace
et je prends le pion pas le fou et après
ça se passerait pas trop mal je crois
et si je défends du style ça
je prends en cas de juste
là j'ai au moins égalisé
et si je fais un truc comme ça
pour défendre avec la
[Musique]
fin voilà salut chacun amateur la finale
il y a pas de finale Mika nous hein en
fait
toute ronde
et il y a
y a la et c'est celui qui aura le plus
de cons qui va gagner
de tes partages
ou autre et du coup on disait Fatou G4
pour clouer et surtout venir défendre le
défenseur du pion des 4 on va manger
avec toutes nos pièces donc je pense que
D4 avait l'air en tout cas intéressant
après ce qu'il fallait voir ce qui est
D4 peut-être mais cavaler prend des
quatre
mais je me demande si c'est pas la même
chose
et après tourner maintenant j'ai plus le
clouage
et là je sais pas si je suis bien enfin
la les noirs sont c'est le noir qui joue
pour la qualité mais j'ai pas encore
récupéré le pion tu vois
non est-ce que tu vas le récupérer
facilement ça la question
mais est-ce que c'est bien prendre
tu bouges je prends un H7
mais j'ai trouvé F5
tu bouges la tour je pourrais manger ici
et si tu bouges le fou a priori je pense
que ça va là pour les Noirs là j'ai
égalisé donc c'est intéressant en tout
cas cette idée de jeu des quatre mamie
je vais fouger 4 en premier
et mais c'est la même idée je pense sur
juste
ça va être nul signé très vite
et si fou ou deux est-ce qu'il y a moyen
de faire tes cartes quand même
je crois qu'il y a je crois que des
Catalans
si je prends du cavalier
est-ce que tu l'as vu
piège
donc en fait sur cavalier quand il faut
que tu manges un A4 si je prends de la
dame tu vas perdre du matériel parce que
je prends la et je prends la et je gagne
et si je prends du pion et bien je vais
venir manger là puis je vais manger là
et là c'est complètement égal et donc
sur faut deux qui est la partie sur des
4 cavaliers prend ça fait nul direct et
scorpion prend et bien je pense faire
en faut prendre
et ca va les prendre à quatre menaçant
le fou et menaçant aussi une belle
fourchette en B3 maintenant quand je
réfléchis je suis pas sûr que je
t'envoie si grave parce que j'ai ma tour
en prise quand même
donc Fatou là il faut il faut être sûr
de nous là
ça peut pas être gênant
ouais mais peut-être que je peux me
[Musique]
je m'en fous pour empêcher ça
ah oui mais en fait c'est très fort on
va vite très fort
e mais en plus
[Musique]
tu rentres tu aimes peut-être tour des 8
histoire de dire je te oui mais en fait
j'ai au moins te prendre les deux au
moins ça
qui donne l'avantage probablement être
encore plus fort d'ailleurs quand tu
l'as dit
faut bouger
découverte en fait ça
peut vraiment
être ça qui va attaquer on s'enlève
d'ici j'ai plus qu'à vallée B3 à cause
de foutrant
il faut voir je sais pas s'il y a des
s'il y a des trucs
mais c'est vrai que ça a large au moins
de très échec est prise en B2 donc
[Musique]
oui
tu prends linge rouge tu as quand même
trois tons pour la pierre mes pièces
sont assez actives je pense que ça peut
être très très dur pour les blancs
très thématique Fatou
près de mal jouer
mais un truc comme ça oups
tu as déjà vu plein de fois dans la
période et mat oui énormément de fois
qui pourrait avoir lieu enfin tout
et 3 si je vais là bon je sais pas dans
quel sens mais ça peut être
dangereux pour les blancs dans tous les
cas on a des pièces très actives chez
les noirs on a laissé la pièce même pour
trois pions
je suis pas sûr que ma tête
mais voilà en tout cas ça serait
difficile Magnus elle est noire alors
bien sûr il est plus fort que Mama girof
mais bon à ce niveau-là
on joue quand même pour l'égalité
en premier lieu et avec les noirs bien
souvent faire des jouets donc Magnus en
juin des 4 et ben il accepte en gros de
faire nul je pense hein
[Musique]
mais en fait ce qui est important de
voir à ce niveau là c'est que les
joueurs je cherche pas forcément à tout
prix à gagner même si Magnus et bien sûr
qu'il veut gagner
alors en fait Magnus
c'est pas non plus magicien quoi en face
alors d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a dit je
crois que c'était hier enfin il y a deux
jours un truc comme ça il l'a dit dans
une interview dans une longue interview
qu'il a fait
so il a dit que gagner
avec les Noirs c'est quasiment
impossible si au travers ça en face ne
veut pas perdre
et en fait il y a tellement les gens
sont tellement forts ils sont tellement
bien préparés dans les ouvertures que si
tu veux pas perdre avec tes blancs à ce
niveau là et ben en fait ça c'est facile
ils ont assez de connaissance et sont
tellement forts les joueurs pour réussir
vraiment à
très bien sûr bon il y a des joueurs qui
sont plus compétitifs que d'autres qui
veulent plus gagner que d'autres mais là
ici c'est ma médiérophe il décide de pas
perdre Magnus
a priori avec les Blancs il y a pas
grand chose à faire
voilà et prendre du cavalier qu'elle va
les prendre puis on prend il faut
prendre fou ça ça va faire ça c'est une
là enfin tout on a on l'avait tout vu le
début d'ailleurs peut-être même qu'il va
faire
tac tac et tour des buts alors je sais
pas laquelle il peut manger là mais il
va faire de la colonne moi je verrais
bien un tour des 8 d'abord
pas le temps de défendre
le pion des quatre
donc on va pouvoir récupérer
[Musique]
et sur ça
non je regardais tour des cinq mais ça
m'a l'air un petit peu tout le match
sur le classement mais je pense que la
partie la partie la plus difficile c'est
les deux Américains car Wana est sceaux
parce que Carolina est en tête et en
tête depuis un bon moment et s'il arrive
à maintenir
son avance ça peut ça peut très très
bien tourner pour lui
donc vous avez le classement qui est
affiché là devant vous
donc les trois Américains qui sont en
tête 14,5 12,5
[Musique]
qui sont là en train de de jouer à ce
moment la troisième place c'est pas très
très loin et je vous rappelle aussi
que
les points le barème quand vous gagnez
une partie vous gagnez 3 points
quand vous faites nul vous gagnez un
point chacun mais il y aura un demi
point de bonus en plus pour le gagnant
de l'Armageddon qui aura lieu du coup en
cas de nul en partie classique
donc là
il est très très bien là pour le coup il
a un petit nid d'avance
mais par Nakamura c'est hyper contre
Wesley et ben en fait il est derrière
là c'est Wesley qui joue non pardon
c'était Nakamura qui joue contre non
c'est ceux qui jouent contre Carolin
en fait chaud si gagne mes deux parties
classiques qui arrivent il peut gagner
tendre
donc c'est pas simple
mais en fait
il est très très bien
il est quasiment imprenable mais après
même un goût caisse peut revenir à la
deuxième place quoi enfin en fait c'est
encore jouable même si on a l'impression
que que c'est mort c'est pas de sa mort
en train de m'imaginer Fisher qui
verrait ce classement il ne prendrait
pas j'en ai qu'un devant et pas un Russe
ouais bon en plus là à quelqu'un qui
court en ce moment voilà il y a pas trop
de rue s'inviter de manière générale
avec ce qui se passe en Ukraine
pour que je pense qu'il comprendrait là
mais c'est vrai que que les Russes de
manière générale c'est un petit peu
moins présents sur la scène mondiale
maintenant
oui non c'est clair à l'époque il y
avait 10 rue c'est un américain
et maintenant c'est un peu l'inverse
c'est un petit peu l'inverse maintenant
alors j'ai trois bon là on va voir tout
revu
le G6 propose nul merci au revoir
donc excusez-moi donc c'est passé tout
ce qu'on avait dit franchement Fatou on
est pas mal pour l'instant
en fait si tu regardes à l'époque de
Fisher le temps des candidats par
exemple et ben tu avais quasiment que
des Russes
et
maintenant tu avais quoi
tu as
tu as plus de choses tu as plus qu'à
[Musique]
apparemment de renouveau en fait si tu
veux dans les Russes
montantes russes
blagues genre comme ça du bof et les
pauvre il a pas de niveau pour jouer
pour je les candidats
ouf mais il a 27 10 quoi 27 20 max
des candidats c'est top 10 mondial quand
même il est pas dans le top 10
donc
non je le considère pas comme un
prétendantes en tout cas
même si c'est un
joueur que j'admire énormément très très
créatif et très très bon d'ailleurs de
bof
mais c'est pas un prénom donc en fait
pour ce tournoi de boeuf est-ce qu'il
est juste bon il aurait sa place quand
même
mais
ça va être la quand tu vois
[Musique]
les joueurs ben
n'a qu'à moi
[Musique]
c'est le top du top quoi tu vois c'est
le top du top avec quelques stars
montantes comme ça
[Musique]
aire
local
ça arrive alors Paris il est là parce
que ben il est local mais si il n'était
pas norvégien il serait jamais là
donc donc voilà quoi
il y a personne en fait ce soit tout
bœuf qui vient en tête
oui je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
mais après c'est même pas forcément le
déclin c'est qu'en fait les échecs sont
de plus en plus populaires de manière
générale et que à l'époque il y avait
que la Russie qui enfin surtout la
Russie qui qui s'intéresse aux échecs et
maintenant
[Musique]
et c'est plus aussi facile qu'à l'époque
j'ai envie de dire
et pourtant il m'en faut mentir parce
que tout début je disais que ma médiathe
c'est un joueur qui qui était pas
pleutre qui jouait pour le gain et ben
non
et d'un an on a pas eu le temps de
pronostiquer
vraiment dur pour Magnus parce que
Magnus fait un tournoi l'un pour
l'instant en 8 parties il a gagné aucune
partie ok il a encore rien gagné et
il a encore rien gagné
et
ils attendent
ent il a encore rien gagné et
malheureusement il le sait quand il a
les noirs
et demi je pense être comme ça
je te dis je vais te dire combien
mais bon c'est beaucoup en fait si
Magnus il bat
si
tu as gagné trois points quand il fait
nul et bien un et demi quoi c'est trop
dur tu vois ce niveau là c'est
[Musique]
parce que j'ai vu qu'il a fait nul
contre guéri pendant contre
et c'est la goûter 1
donc ouais hyper un point et du Magnus
quand il quand il perd et quand il fait
nul contre un genre de ce niveau là et
quand il gagne environ 3
donc imagine que il faut qu'il batte
en fait il gagne quasiment quand elle
est le ban tout le temps quoi c'est trop
dur à ce niveau-là
donc ok c'est parti qui est terminée
déjà c'est un peu rapide mais on
s'attendait du l'ouverture
et souvent c'est ça rien en fin de
tournoi plus gros de Magnus tu dis ouais
je fais une rapide je prends deux points
à vélo tu vois
c'est un peu la facilité mais pour
Marius c'est hyper dur voyez un petit
peu le mérite qu'il a Magnus d'avoir
réussi à monter un élo aussi élevé alors
que dès qu'il fait une nuit il perd la
maison quoi
je t'ai dit par la maison parce que le
rapport nulle gain mais enfin c'est pas
en perdre c'est ce qui réussit à faire
c'est comme ça qu'il est monté
ça limite la casse mais c'est sûr que
c'est très très compliqué
il a pas de compte carwana il est perdu
6 points
et pour être Ivan c'est à dire pourquoi
pas perdre de points il faut qu'il
battent deux fois quand même
en gros il le bat deux fois enfin il
gagne 2 1 il est à 0
et bon battre un joueur qui a 27 60
c'est extrêmement dur même si c'est
magique
et une défaite tu perds 15 points 15
points et l'eau à ce niveau là va tous
c'est énorme c'est
quand il fait un bon tournoi et qui
gagne trois points dans le tournoi il
est content
donc la part de 15 en entendant c'est
extrêmement
mais lui il y a personne plus fort que
lui en fait personne qui a plus de l'eau
et en plus tous les joueurs ont perdu un
peu des points et l'eau tout ça et ça
devient hyper dur là le numéro 2 il a
quand même 60 points qu'est-ce que tu
fais
on porte
juste qu'il est
il disait en fait il avait marre de la
main il est au top depuis 10 ans
maintenant
il va juste le prendre plus à la légère
quoi
mais après les 200900 et l'eau
je crois qu'il le sait qu'il donnera
jamais
c'est sûr
enfin c'est sûr on sait jamais mais là
non mais c'est trop dur
à dire que c'est plus sa priorité d'être
numéro 1 ça s'est vu qu'il a lâché le
titre de champion du monde
[Musique]
voilà avant qu'il y en a un qui arrive
et encore quelques années mais bon
[Musique]
ça va
jusqu'à quand bah écoute éternellement
éternellement là si tu cherches carrosse
il a 2812 depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans qui n'a pas joué donc tu gardes ton
élo mais après ils s'en enfin
c'est la de jouer
c'est pas c'est pas pour regarder son
record historique non tu vas pas arrêter
pour ce qu'il y en a qui vont faire par
exemple sur tetescom on voit bon bah
j'ai atteint les 2000 j'arrête de jouer
parce que j'ai 2000 c'est pas le but il
faut jouer on est là pour jouer donc
vous inquiétez pas
déjà si on les attend une fois on peut
les ratteindre et puis si on descend bah
c'est pas grave c'est il y a pas de
problème là heureusement que Carlson il
s'arrête pas là en disant que ça 60
points d'avance sur tout le monde bon
j'arrête ma carrière ici ce serait bien
bien triste
parce qu'il aime ça et après on peut un
peu le comprendre si il a pas fait le
enfin s'il a arrêté le cycle de champion
du monde qu'il arrête un peu tout ça en
fait à un moment donné quand tu es
numéro un tout le temps et que tu as pas
l'adversaire vraiment pour pour
concurrencer même toi te concurrencer
quoi
et ben en fait
tu as réussi à atteindre un peu toutes
les objectifs
tu vois et tu en as plus quoi simplement
et bon de 1900 et l'autre c'est c'est
vraiment beaucoup trop difficile
et c'est pour ça que je pense que voilà
mais dans toute façon
là je pense que son prochain objectif
c'est de te faire plaisir et de faire
plus de tournoi quand il aura envie de
faire et de plus faire ce cycle de
champion du monde qui dure des mois et
des mois les préparations tout ça et
c'est beaucoup trop de travail et lui il
veut être plus tranquille là il a il est
en phase où il veut se reposer un peu et
changer un peu de perspective
le jour où je passe tout en stream
j'arrête tout
mais écoute route un petit peu plus haut
que je trouve
ne t'arrête pas là écoute vas-y fonce
tous ces qu'une première étape dans ta
carrière
si j'en ai marre de route je ferai
exprès
ça c'est un petit peu non je le ferai
pas trop mais mais après
t'as vu j'ai failli perdre malin une
fois
j'avais donné madame
non mais ça arrive après on est humain
une partie une partie ça ça peut se
perdre une saute gagner c'est vite
arrivé quelque part mais bon parti c'est
qu'une partie c'est pas extrêmement
significative surtout si c'est internet
qu'il y a un missclic
il faut pas
faut pas s'arrêter à ça
mais après je comprends la fierté quand
même de pouvoir battre tout
donc je te le souhaite aussi
[Rires]
bon en tout cas qui roule qui fait son
ouverture
c'est une position à peu près normale
il faut en G2 dans
cette structure avant d'espagnol tu vois
c'est le fou était ici et le pion ici je
te dirai c'est une espagnole en fait
mais il y a un fond donc foot 17 on peut
avoir comme c'est vite on fera plein de
choses
comment est-ce que ça va se dérouler
Fatou faux 3 alors attention en plus on
regarde souvent c'est un pion qui est
donné mais là il y a plein de tactiques
je pense qui permettent de ne pas perdre
par exemple ça ça et éventuellement il y
a de la découverte derrière il y a même
fou prend un souci qui est possible avec
le cavalier qui va être perdu ici et
même le fou qui peut s'ouvrir tu vois
même du cavalier prend le 5 par exemple
et un petit peu bloqué derrière ces
pions par contre si on l'ouvre en fait
on est content et parfois on peut
vouloir donner un pion juste pour ouvrir
à ouvrir les diagonales et rendre ces
pièces plus active donc c'est un mal
pour un bien mais bon là le pire on va
même être récupéré sûrement mais on
pourrait juste le donner pour s'ouvrir
donc donc oui ça ça irait pas de manger
donc faut trois ça me coûte
développement on peut imaginer plus tard
dessin qui est tout reprendre ou
cavaliers de un truc comme ça et puis
bah écoute
[Musique]
position normale mais qui sort un peu du
commun quand même parce que le fou il
eng2
et donc voilà à voir si
[Musique]
Ali raisin arrive à
des stabiliser guérir dans cette
position qui est un peu bizarre
alors sinon qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste
il nous reste à boussothorov contre Ikao
donc le cavalier de
Naka qui qui fait des bons
qui fait des bons regardez regardez-moi
ça on s'est arrêté tout à l'heure
ici là je cave à des C4 pour jouer le
dessin et abdouna pas résisté et il a
joué ici le couper trois
pour chasser le cavalier à cause de
l'ouverture de la de la diagonale du
mais peut-être que tu peux je sais que
peut-être tu pouvais
5 cavalier 17
fois la même pièce dans l'ouverture
dans les débutants bien sûr
ce que permet
lui c'est ce qui fait
et A4 pour essayer de prendre de
l'espace ici et chasse escalier et
cavaliers 5 donc le cavalier qui qui
bouge 18 fois
pour laisser passer le fou et encore
cavaluer cette incroyable ce cavalier il
aura fait quoi alors je pense qu'on va
bientôt on va avoir Naka qui va venir au
conventionnel parce que bah écoute je
pense qu'il va venir un peu narguer
ce cavalier ce cavalier qui avait
combien de cases depuis le début je
crois qu'on va pas faire notre
pronostics
4 5 6 7 coups avec le même cavalier
en 13 coups c'est un truc de fou quand
même
13 coups cette fois le même cavalier qui
a bougé
et en plus c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini je pense que là il est en
train de me préparer un petit confession
et là il levait il est pas sa chaise je
pense qu'il parle au public à la caméra
et qui est bientôt on va avoir une
confession qu'on va s'empresser de
regarder je vais nous expliquer un petit
peu tous ces mouvements de cavaliers
donc faut tout dans 5 minutes on va
avoir la partie de chaque contre Magnus
en arnaque et donc
ça marche
[Musique]
il avait dit quoi il avait dit je fais
durer la partie et en fait c'est une
carence
tu sais que bientôt dans huit jours
maintenant presque une semaine bientôt
je vais participer à un tournoi qui va
peut-être
me permettre de te passer mettre le
National et
j'aime beaucoup la cadence
elle est hyper drôle la cadence
et ben j'ai jamais joué comme ça donc
toi peut-être que oui mais pour moi non
c'est nouveau dans cette enceinte qui me
qui m'étonne mais ok dis-moi tout la
cadence de mon tournoi
c'est une heure plus 30 secondes par
coup
oui c'est assez courant bah oui pour moi
non en fait
[Musique]
à l'époque les tournois moins de 2200
c'est un peu comme ça
et maintenant bah ils l'ont mis à moins
de 2400 depuis peu
et j'avais jamais vu de ton bras comme
ça donc moi je tout le temps
1h30
mais
pourquoi pas en fait c'est quand tu veux
faire un tournoi lent mais que tu as un
weekend
et ben non mais
du coup bah tu fais une heure 30
secondes et puis tu
es parti c'est sur trois jours qu'on
peut faire en France c'est quand même
les doubles rondes 1h30 + 30 secondes et
ouais mais là
moi c'est trois jours mais en fait tu as
si tu regardes bien mon tournoi c'est tu
as deux rondes le vendredi avec la
première ronde à 16 heures
ce qui veut dire que le temps d'arriver
ce qui veut dire que bon soit tu
travailles et que tu arrives à t'en
sortir etc et tu viens pour la ronde
hein toi tu prends un bail tu arrives à
la ronde de qu'à 19 heures
après samedi tu travailles pas peut-être
et tu joues dans trois parties et
dimanche tu as deux parties une à 9h du
matin une à midi c'est un truc de fou ça
va trop vite mais d'un autre côté bon
moi je suis un très vite donc c'est
comment ça ça me va bien je pense une
heure pour 30 secondes par coup je
trouve que c'est moi j'aime bien ça va
vite plus jeune en fait
dans ces cadence là et d'ailleurs je moi
ce que je détestais c'était les cadences
enfin les cadence française qu'on a tout
le temps une heure plus de 30 secondes
par 1h30 secondes par coup avec une
demi-heure de rajouter un tiers en cas
d'horreur moi j'adore ça
tu vois à chaque fois enfin moi je joue
vite et c'est assez rare où je suis
vraiment mal au temps
et
donc j'arrive souvent à amener une
adversaire en diagnotte
et une fois je compte il reste 10 coups
avant le take note ok il faut que je
trouve une peu banane que
et du coup mais je suis comme ça et
parce que j'ai toujours beaucoup
d'avance autant donc en fait je cherche
un petit peu à semer la zizanie et
j'avoue quand généralement quand
l'incrément du 40e arrive je suis un peu
dingue et ça m'arrive très souvent et en
Espagne tu as jamais quasiment jamais ça
toutes les parties c'est 1h30 30
secondes par coup et là tu peux flag en
règle et
là maintenant les tournois qui font une
heure plus 30 secondes par coup c'est
génial
après c'est moins de 2400 et là je suis
à 2399 donc écoute je sais pas si enfin
on va voir ce qui se passe cet été mais
peut-être que je pourrais pas les faire
en fait
mais
peut-être que j'ai quand même pas mal
juste la terre je vais retourner là
jusqu'au 18 après du 22 je pars aux
Canaries faire un tournoi par équipe
jusqu'au 25
et après en juillet
je crois que je vais avoir
du 21 31 comme ça et après
au mois de août
du 5 au 11 j'ai normalement un
championnat enfin un open pareil et
après j'ai le championnat d'Espagne par
équipe du 13 au 18 comme ça donc j'ai
quand même 4 tournois ouais et ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas autant joué sur
un été c'est ouf donc j'ai quand même
beaucoup de parties à faire donc aussi
bien à la fin mettez le 2300 quoi aussi
bien j'ai des MI4 il peut censé plein de
choses et j'aimerais bien passer
coefficient 10 au cas où pour pas lâcher
de toute ma vie
si je suis amoureux de toi
pour ceux qui savent pas
c'est 1400 et l'eau tout va pour avoir
le titre de mettre international et le
coefficient 10 dans les parties donc
perdre et gagner moins de points qui te
permet de
ne pas te prendre des moins 50 sur les
tournois ça peut être agréable
oui voilà par exemple Magnus
si je prends par exemple allez tout le
monde connaît tout le monde connaît
Libye
qui a 2500 € et ben un joueur de son élo
et ben il a gagné 5 points parce qu'il
écoute bien 10 moi actuellement
coefficient 20 si je veux un joueur de
mon élo je gagne 10 points
et il y a certains joueurs qui sont
coefficients encore 40
quand il bat un joueur il gagne 20
points et donc une fois que tu passes
une fois dans ta vie de 1400 hello et
ben tu passes coefficient 10 et donc du
coup ben les paris des points et l'eau
ils sont moins élevés donc tu gagnes
moins de points mais tu en perds aussi
moins et c'est comme ça que ça mais
c'est vraiment la cour des grands
c'est Libye babylette aujourd'hui au Top
16 vu qu'ils ont quasiment
j'ai pas vu mais oui exactement
d'ailleurs 5 points en jeu des deux
côtés
par exemple
et voilà donc c'est ça qui est joué donc
c'est une structure assez solide ou les
blancs quand même on avance de enfin ils
ont plus d'espace à l'eldame et blanc
vont essayer d'attaquer
la structure là ah si c'est un coin
intéressant enfin tu vois
est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut jouer à
je sais pas
ce qui est clair c'est que sur racisme
on n'a pas envie de manger parce que
après faut prendre
la structure des Noirs serait affaiblie
et j'ai pas eu ton cher
il suffit de faire un plan pour les
attaquer
et ce pion qui peut être à la fois fort
ou faible sur le long terme c'est pas
trop trop encore c'est qu'en final ça
peut être très fort avec peu de pièces
parce qu'une tour par exemple qui pourra
peut-être passer aller manger le pion et
pousser après derrière ça peut être ça
peut être fort mais dans l'autre ça peut
aussi être faible si jamais il y a des
pièces qui sont changées ça peut il peut
très bien en fin de partie
et je pense aussi à B5 d'ailleurs qui
est possible là il y a pas de prise en
passant attention c'est le pion était
ici il y aurait pu avoir une
présentation éventuellement mais là je
peux pas manger encore et peut-être non
je préfère dame B6 celui de fou prend à
6 c'est peut-être possible
moi j'arrive pas à faire mes flèches
voilà
et donc c'est possible après faut voir
si j'arrive pas je C4 en tout casser le
centre
compliqué salut RKM
bienvenue à toi
donc à voir si c'est possible mais au
pire BK
après la structure tu vois enfin tout
c'est un peu comme le français des
changes au final
ça symétrique donc les Noirs jouent un
peu sur ça ils se disent bon ok c'est
juste peut-être que je peux faire nul
enfin je voulais l'égalité et bien sûr
Naka il est noir donc il joue pour
l'égalité c'est parfaitement normal
Fatou j'ai raté ma grosse j'ai raté
Magnus
vous avez du dessus vous avez la vue du
dessus sur le chignon de Magnus
magnifique
tout le monde est un peu fan de son son
petit chignon alors on va essayer de
rattraper très vite hop hikao
confessionnal je viens d'avoir une vidéo
de professionnel de des carreaux je le
savais hein
ça va être cool très vite
les plans doivent gagner à tout prix
pour prendre le demi point
supplémentaire
ils ont 3 minutes de plus à la pendule
au départ qui ont bien couler les 3
minutes de temps
et tu vois ce petit pion assis encore
une fois c'est un peu comme un
appartient de d'un cas et Abdou ce qui
peut se passer ce pion en finale ça peut
être très très fort par exemple si
jamais je mets un cavalier là-bas ou je
peux un jour ouvrir un petit peu la
position tout casser et mettre un
foulard et aller manger là-bas ce
potentiellement ce pion il peut être
extrêmement fort comme potentiellement
ce plan il peut être faible si les tours
sont échangés je peux aller manger je
peux aller faire ça et ça par exemple
si les tours sont changés par exemple
donc ce pion il peut être à la fois fort
et à la fois pas fort
donc il y a eu des cinq de jeux de ma
news moi j'aime bien les Noirs ici
et oui par rapport à ce que
effectivement quand on continue devant
un échiquier en vrai le temps passe très
vite je te rends pas compte on commence
à calculer un truc qui est en calcul
10000 choses
sauf que très très vite et moi
[Musique]
après je considère avoir un bon grain
par toi
et ça ça aide vachement quand on a un
bon réparateur quand on est bien ces
lignes bien les idées de nos ouvertures
et ben c'est vrai qu'on gagne beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à la pendule
et parce qu'on sait ce qu'on fait on est
rassuré on sait qu'on fait des bons
coups on connaît les variantes pas
besoin de réfléchir à 1000 trucs et
c'est vrai que ça aide beaucoup ça aide
beaucoup au final
ici et peut-être qu'on peut voir un
cavalier B8 arrivé
c'est une idée et ce pion qui peut être
à la fois fort et à la fois on va faire
même cavaler à 5 et tu lui dépends
qu'il y a quand même un problème sur le
cavalier même je suis pas sûr au final
c'est une fois que tu as mangé là il
peut y avoir un problème
par exemple cavalier B8 ou des deux et
bien de 4
ok
il va tomber sur le long terme le cible
tranquillement et si la occasion va le
prendre mais sinon on n'est pas pressé
et là c'est toujours bien bien placé au
centre
et si les blancs va la tout prix rester
sur A pour le protéger bon il finira par
le prendre donc
là l'enjeu des blancs c'est de conserver
bien sur ce petit pion mais aussi de
de jouer et de jouer un peu plus
peut-être au centre
et là j'aime pas ce que fait
j'aime pas trop ce qu'il fait
il a pas obtenu grand chose
d'accablement ici il est même moins bien
Magnus doit faire nul pour gagner leur
magasin
il veut mater non
[Musique]
c'est marrant
j'ai la nul j'attends j'attends ma nul
tranquille ça me suffit pour gagner le
demi-point non non
je veux pas que ça gagne
pas encore le gains
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va manger là
et faire tourner je pense pas je pense
que quand même pas mal
et après un truc du style cavalier 5
attaquer l'arme lorsque la F3 alors
quand même pas mal enfin tout seul
avec un pion qui va tomber
même G4
extrêmement fort
ce qui a plus de temps la pendule faire
attention là deux minutes 30 je vous
rappelle incrément c'est une seconde
d'incrément à partir du 40ème coup et là
ils sont encore au 27ème coup pour
l'instant et ben écoutez pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de rajouter
[Musique]
à la pendule
pourquoi il est dit à quoi là
effectivement c'est ce qu'il fait
ça marche malade bah écoute je sais pas
de quoi tu parles mais bon courage à toi
j'espère que
courage je sais pas ce que ça peut être
mais tu nous diras en tout cas un bon
courage à toi bonne journée
genre on voit là on voit le mec un petit
thé on voit que ça se passe pas bien
mais là
le pauvre il mérite pas tout ça
il mérite pas tout ça
car c'est une gagnée
F3 voilà ce matin c'est le matin
donc tu peux bien sûr sacrifier la
qualité pour avoir la case ici mais bon
là j'ai
18 ans en plus mais est-ce que vraiment
Fatou non ça marche pas
mais attention il a fait G4 on en a
parlé aussi la venue ce qui a plus de
temps la pendule il reste 28 minutes
pardon 28 coups pareil il lui reste 12
coups pardon on ouvre 21e coups du reste
12 coups à jouer pour avoir un incrément
de une seconde donc là on a 12 coups à
faire sans accrément Magnus qui va
devoir faire du Bullet là attention
la qualité j'ai l'impression que ça va
mal se passer
là
je pense aussi rkpm je pense aussi
je pense qu'il est un peu placé sur
tournoi en style ouais bon là il a les
noirs
et du coup bah il veut il veut s'amuser
il veut essayer de gagner faire une
bonne partie
je le vois aussi un peu comme ça rkpm et
c'est clair que c'est c'est cool quand
il a une position où il peut jouer pour
le gain parce que franchement la
première il a pas pu faire grand-chose
2 minutes 13 pour un mediaf
c'est un
sur un tournoi c'est un marathon
des chèques
[Musique]
prise il faut jouer cavalier F3
et le problème de F3 c'est que
tu vas devoir peut-être prendre la
qualité
OK
je pense tous les pions
37 secondes il lui reste 9 minutes par 9
coups par an pour jouer pour arriver à
un incrément c'est hyper chaud mais si
c'est une menace puis on prend et A7
attention peut-être cavaler ces 6 va
être obligatoire pour jeter B4
il laisse
quoi là
un truc on ira voir après
ça marche pour Magnus
20 secondes on croise 6
il va se faire flag 6 coups à jouer en
10 secondes vous pouvez changer les
tours
quand même
je suis pas sûr
allez hop on imagine que j'ai bien
compris c'est ce qu'il a fait
et maintenant il attend il monte le roi
16 secondes il reste trois coups à faire
bon il va réussir à les faire
et ce pion qui qui est fait ma news qui
appart pour ses petits pions mais
celui-là c'est le plus important bon je
réussir à manger celui-là
on est au 48e
à
avoir à son incrément
et il a pas laissé enfin il n'a pas de
manger depuis
ouais mais comment je fais maintenant
comment je fais pour ces 7 ca va aller
prendre un 6
ça a l'air pas avant ça va non
ça a l'air pas pour les blancs comment
tu défends
voilà jauge qui donne un avantage blanc
donc je comprends pas
peut-être ça ça
a compris
celui-là c'est de
Fatou c'est gagnant pour les noirs
avec avec les Blancs plus rien faire
surtout là je fais dames et je pousse
l'autre
j'ai eu un doute à la partie il y avait
pas eu tu prends des six possible
ou est-ce que je suis où est-ce que je
suis juste nul
je vais mettre l'ordi
il s'en fout en fait l'ordi
j'ai quand même pas mal calculé
c'est pareil en fait il joue quelle
année contre le retour
mais bon
[Musique]
je peux pas partir ok bon j'ai pas trop
halluciné quoi c'était possible
finale et ici moi je te dis hein moi je
me sens empressé de manger à 6 parce que
j'ai pas envie de donner des contre-jour
c'est vrai est-ce que tu n'es pas car
à 7 C3 et là le seul coquillage pardon
il y a eu deux c'est le cookie
apparemment pour les Noirs parce que
j'ai le trait
et il y a plein de choses à faire
même cavaler l'échec et B5 par exemple
alors pas si mal j'ai quand même mon roi
en sécurité et un pion out Magnus qui
vient dans la main c'est la bonne
nouvelle de la journée m'agus qui qui
revient plus dans ce tournoi quand même
et alors si on revient un petit peu sur
les parties de tournoi ça terminé on a
cette partie entre Ali raisin et guéri
on a guéri à la caméra qui se frotte les
yeux
donc écoute bah pour l'instant elle a
quand même on a les raisins qui a fait
G4 et ça c'est un coup assez
[Musique]
incroyable un coup de digne de thé vert
menthe alors attends
fous des 7 fouet
4 alors ici tout le monde ferait roi H2
n'est-ce pas pour défendre le pion H3 et
sortir des pièces etc mais à lire ça qui
fait G4
G4 pour prendre de l'espace et dire très
souvent enfin tout va venir manger 3
pour venir en F5 ou alors celui-là qui
va venir en H4 et aussi en F5 tu as
plein d'idées de ce type là qui sont
intéressantes
parce que je fais j'ai 5
mais maintenant que tu fais un truc du
style cavalier H7
tu tac là
quand tu fais ça ben j'ai peut-être des
idées à base de tout
pour mettre mon cavalier ici
et ici et depuis que j'ai 6 avec mon fou
etc taper ce qu'on peut en H4 ça c'est
un plan très thématique on voit souvent
et ça a l'air pas mal pour les noirs
G4 alors faut prendre G4 peut-être pas
mais
un sacrifice qui peuvent arriver mais je
pense pas je pense qu'il y a pas assez
de jeu
je pense qu'il y a pas assez de gens en
fait pas trop tu veux manger mais
je vais venir je vais défendre mes
pièces ça c'est dans je crois pas du
tout enfin tout
non je vais faire des changer les fous
on va changer les dames franchement j'y
crois tu manques de pièces sur la tête
je pense pas que ce soit viable il y a
eu tout revu
quand tu sais que derrière
tu as du monde pour aller le terminer et
que tu vas au moins récupérer quelque
chose soit le matériel soit tu t'y vas
pour
sacrifier pour pour mater
sont trop loin pour la vague de maths
donc un peu de mal à
avoir ça
il n'y a pas assez de pièces ouais
effectivement alors dans la partie de
Google je peux aller voir si tu veux
c'est passé un truc assez marrant
C6
donc enfin tout on va voir on va on va
essayer de voir comment on est arrivé là
alors on s'est arrêté bon au tout début
c'était
une un système de Londres
et on ajoute B6 avec les Noirs H4
H4 dans ces positions c'est assez
marrant
donc le but c'est d'essayer de
jouer cavalier 5
et plus tard ou deux et serrage 5 c'est
tapez comme ça sur la colonnage ouvrir
ici et si les Noirs je vois H5 et ben
des fois on est censé être content parce
qu'on a affaiblit un petit peu la
diagonale et les pions du roi noir
donc il y a eu ces cinq donc
affaiblissement halal réaction au centre
c'est tout à fait normal
H5 et maintenant cache-5 menace et ben
les Noirs donc rien de tarif joue
lui-même H5 pour empêcher des blancs de
faire ce coup là et là on a eu qu'il y
avait les C6 de Strasbourg et sur Caval
et C6 c'est quoi
donc B4 donc c'est un quoi assez logique
enfin tout hein ce qu'il veut faire
Google c'est essayer d'ouvrir un petit
peu ce jeu là si tu prends ici je prends
et je pourrais appuyer un peu mon
cavalier que la tour c'est un jeu P5
essayez de fixer mon petit cavalier en
C6 franchement il est pas mal de
cavalier
et après si je joue ces quatre quand
même la possibilité pour je bais5 à 4 et
aussi on va se centre maintenant qui est
fermé peut-être qu'un jour on aura la
possibilité de pouvoir jouer F3 et E4
blanche moi j'aime bien
mais bon
tu veux on a tous les deux fait H4 et H5
je pense pas qu'elle soit grave ni pour
l'année pour l'autre pour l'instant la
dame noire en 8 elle a quand même assez
triste
donc
après bon B7 reste une possibilité et
puis même maintenant regarde ben écoute
l'idée de faire E5 ça va être une idée
qui a un moment donné va être va être
alors du jour peut-être pas de suite
parce que là tu perdrais un pion je suis
trop de fois dessus pardon avec mon
cavalier mon fou mais un truc du style
alors je sais pas si c'est possible
ça reste possible
essayer d'ouvrir un petit peu le jeu et
ouvrir des fous quoi
donc avoir en tout cas j'aime bien
l'idée et j'aime bien quand même ce que
crée ici
donc on va voir un peu ce qui est ce qui
peut faire moi j'aime bien j'aime bien
les blancs
on n'a pas fait dans Paris
ok
je suis prêt à marquer tes résultats
Fatou
on est d'accord
fille
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de
pas envie d'armée
moi je moi j'étais entre Abdou blanc et
nul
tu vois comme ça on fait pas
et donc je me suis dit bon je prendrai
celui qui dira enfin je prendrai l'autre
inverse et comme tu disais comme tu m'as
dit l'autre je sais pas quoi
ça peut fonctionner aussi
alors je mets nul que je t'arrêt tu mets
un zéro
[Musique]
c'est le plus probable si on écoute ça
je vois vraiment pas je pense ça fera
nul tous les jours
après
on se calme une structure qui a l'air
assez égale
firoguiri bon c'est point
d'interrogation quand même
se passer G4 et c'est un coup assez
intéressant parce que regarde j'ai pas
défendu quoi
une fois
donc Fatou explique-moi un peu ce qui se
passe s'il te plaît après ça ça est
simple bien sûr que je vais t'expliquer
je trouve merci
[Rires]
et je t'en prie je t'en prie je te
laisse boire un petit peu dehors en
attendant
cette petite dame et un cavalier qui
fait barrage entre les deux donc on a un
moyen de faire une petite découverte une
découverte on va bouger notre cavalier
et une fois qu'on bouge le fou attaque
la dame alors
il faut le bouger de manière pertinente
c'est-à-dire peut-être attaquer une
autre pièce quelle autre pièce chez les
Blancs il y a et qui n'est pas protégé
c'est encore mieux donc dites-moi
je laisse le chat
[Musique]
on se fait avoir dans le jeu de la tour
regardez ici ce qu'on voulait faire
alors je vous explique tu m'auras pas
s'il y a une découverte si je bouge mon
cavalier a priori le fou va attaquer la
dame cavalier 5 attaque là et attaque
aussi ici deux fois bon presque la main
j'ai presque fait de bonnes et là je
vais bouger madame et je perds le
cavalier ça c'est clair
maintenant
si j'allais en B8 on pourrait croire que
je ferai la même chose mais ici il y a
un très joli coucher de dame français
vite on va venir sacrifier contre le fou
c'est vite et après d'un brandam et ben
j'ai très joli
cavalier le 7 fourchette royale qui
récupère
ma pièce et si on compte maintenant et
maintenant les Blancs ont deux pions de
plus en plastique
donc Fatou tu avais une chance sur deux
et tu as réussi à trouver
la bonne case je te félicite
merci c'est pas évident non non
[Musique]
j'ai essayé dommage
mais donc le cavalet qui n'est pas
défendu mais du coup on peut espérer
maintenant que le Caval est parti et
c'est de jouer sans que
à réfléchir la sécurité du roi le
matériel la structure de pion l'espace
l'activité des pièces
c'est groove il est solide
et salut Cécile salut à toi
salut
à moi qui vient de me dire que
qui me féliciter peut-être devenu maître
international
tu sais que ça trompe je vais la faire
tu sais que je vais faire poisser et tu
sais que que il y a tout le monde ça y
est
tu sais que je vais venir commenter ta
tout
je suis au courant de tout alors pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas on va
commencer à vous le dire dès maintenant
et ben
le tournoi que je vais jouer pour
essayer de passer maître national qui se
déroulera du 16 au 18 juin et bien ce
tournoi là et ben il sera commenté en
direct sur ma chaîne par par Fatou et
youmé donc
un deuxième peut-être alors mais pas
plus
on reparlera de ça d'ailleurs pour si
vous voulez qu'on reste tous en contact
avec tout ça enfin tout ah je peux pas
faire de saut tu peux me faire un socle
s'il te plaît bien sûr
donc le petit saut pour pour aller sur
ma chaîne pour ceux qui
qui ne connaîtraient pas ma chaîne pour
ceux qui ne savent pas que le stream
aussi
quand je ne suis pas sur cheescom
et donc n'hésitez pas à venir à
découvrir et à
suivre la chaîne pour plus
d'informations mais moi a priori je vais
revenir sur le stream à partir de ce
week-end sur moi
si vous voulez voir surtout émis en
direct après après 10 ans de maître feed
oui peut-être même plus
je suis passé
je suis passé maître fidd je suis passé
maître fide c'était je crois
en effet
je crois mai 2012 maître fidèle
vous avez 22 ans et maintenant et ben
écoute 11 ans plus tard
11 ans plus tard
c'est dur pourtant
ma première dent
oui oui j'avais une norme
la première dent que j'ai fait j'avais
pas encore j'étais pas encore ma copine
tu es avant je crois bien
parce que
bon je sais pas faire ton parcours je
crois que ma première dame c'était en
c'était
plus je sais plus
je sais plus mais bon
il y aura un décalage avec le direct non
par contre j'aurais pas de caméra je
pense mais bon vous aurez la partie vous
aurez la partie en date vous aurez tout
les liens et tout d'ailleurs je me suis
occupé pour que le tournoi soit
retransmis sur chaise.com en fait parce
que c'était pas le cas il était sur
d'autres sites et j'ai réussi à avoir
l'ordinateur tout ça pour qu'on les
sorties.com quoi ce sera plus facile
pour vous
de
Steph je viens d'arriver je vois que tu
pars de ton prochain tournage te manque
un point pour être Rémi non ça se passe
comment tu dois les passer en virtuel
2004 ou une fois absolument au prochain
relevé et l'eau
alors s'il fallait que je que je sois
premier relevé je pense que je ferai une
partie après je dirais que je suis
malade
mais mais non non maintenant c'est
virtuellement en fait donc si quelqu'un
la première et qu'après je fais 0 peu
importe la première c'est
c'est
ce qui compte voilà d'ailleurs œil de
nuit que je connais très très bien
depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs et de
nuit qui a un
fan invétéré de
lui qui m'avait passé toutes les
musiques à l'époque et derrière il
m'avait aussi passé encore je crois que
je suis pas sûr que les ordures les
trois derniers tomes des caruno GO je
crois je crois que c'est encore chez moi
sauf que ça fait 20 ans que je les ai
piqué et
du coup oui parce qu'en fait là j'ai
récupéré la musique et je pensais mettre
la musique des carologos sur mes streams
ça va être ça va être la folie Fatou
enfin tout elle sait pas encore mais
c'est le meilleur manga du monde
je sais pas je lis pas ben moi non plus
je l'ai pas lu en fait enfin je viens te
dire que j'avais trois à trois mangas
chez moi mais en fait
c'est un animé donc tu peux l'avoir
gratuitement sur Youtube par exemple tu
vas sur Youtube tu as tous les épisodes
et c'est gratuit et en plus sous-titré
la langue que tu veux tu marques
hikaruno 01 VOST FR ça y est c'est parti
tout gratuit et je crois que les trois
enfin l'animé il se termine
trois mangas avant la fin du manga enfin
tu vois je veux dire
la fin j'ai lu les trois derniers mais
sinon c'était tout en animé
c'est génial c'est plus simple de
regarder
ah oui oui moi je préfère
japonais
non mais c'est vrai qu'en fait au final
quand tu regardes
tu apprends plein de petits trucs en
fait c'est un
manga sur le jeu du sur le jeu de Go
c'est un peu comme les échecs sauf que
enfin c'est un contre un c'était blanc
contre le noir sauf que c'est une garde
territoire c'est un peu différent c'est
que des pierres que tu poses c'est pas
des pièces comme comme échecs ou Chucky
ou autre chose et en fait
l'ambiance de tournoi c'est un peu comme
nous pour d'échec là c'est blanc contre
noir c'est des tournois gris américaines
système suisse tu as une pendule enfin
c'est tout pareil en fait et quand tu
vois le goût les joueurs ben ils veulent
battre tiens lui il faut arriver ma
catégorie
il attend de classement enfin tu vois
c'est tout pareil
sauf que nous bah on parle de classement
hello aussi différent mais tu vois c'est
comparable et moi j'ai trouvé cette
série mais génialissime et d'ailleurs si
vous avez vu le manga sur le chat c'est
ikaruno et
ensuite de ça ben moi j'ai appris à
jouer après ça et d'ailleurs si vous
repérez des sur des sites internet
d'échecs des joueurs qui s'appelle Saï
en général c'est moi
et ça vous pouvez vraiment comprendre la
signification que si vous avez vu ou lu
ce manga génial génial Picardo c'est
c'est un truc de fou bref
amuse-toi bien
yes bon courage à toi
bonne soirée et donc donc cavalier G4
été joué est-ce qu'on a d'autres parties
à suivre Fatou qui on a une partie
marrante
qui m'intéresse un petit peu
et pourquoi t'intéresse erwana et
pourquoi pas
attention
enfin tout alors
donc dame B7 ça joue très vite on va
revenir un petit peu au début on s'est
arrêté à tout re 8 on avait dit quoi on
avait dit qu'il y avait des coups
possibles avec avec du XIX je crois
qu'il a joué aucun des deux fois
comme tu le disais il y a plein de plans
possibles et il a joué plus tranquille
avec vous mais cette ouais en fait tu
peux temporiser
[Musique]
4 voilà
prise en 4 donc à pion isolé pour les
blancs mais plus d'espace
car elle était 7 fougée 5 rien de fou
mais ça change assez
tour 1
et je sens que ça va bientôt répéter
Fatou
mais ouais je vois bien le dame là
peut-être qu'il y a quand même une
pression blanche en fait des fois très
très vite
il peut aussi manger dans manger là
manger là mange là ramener la tour ici
mais je pense que j'ai tourné 8 j'ai eu
droit et suite et tu pars avec ta tour
et c'est complètement égal je pense pas
tout qu'on va assister à une nul rapide
là aussi
il est
il est en forme de retournoy je tours
c'est un excuse-moi je
sous-estime un petit peu mon ami à mon
avis carvana
et le temps d'avance il fait bien je
pense que c'est plus logique
ce qui est beau c'est qu'il veut sa
partie en fait je pense que s'il fait
nul dans cette partie le tournoi est
quasiment gagné en fait mais lui au-delà
de tout ça ben il veut juste aux échecs
et continue quoi et là il sait qu'il est
pas du tout en danger il peut l'avoir
plus tard c'est ça il peut se permettre
de
continuer et d'essayer de
trifouiller un petit peu pour voir si il
peut pas la gagner
en tout cas il peut mettre une pression
gratuite quoi
parce que regarde ça
tu as un problème là-dessus
et là dessus
si tu manges tu as un problème là-dessus
et même cavalier dessin
tu as un problème là-dessus aussi en
fait tu es jamais vraiment tranquille
avec les Noirs il y a toujours des trucs
en prise même ça par exemple ça ça pète
un problème
tu bouges je prends la tête pour débute
va réussir à descendre mais tu vois
qu'en fait il y a tout qui
qui tient sur un fil quoi et il y a donc
il y a une certaine pression quand même
proposer ici par un qui fait que c'est
pas si simple donc même si la pollution
reste peut-être égale au vu de la jauge
je vous au vu de la position
et ben carvana il sait que il joue et il
met une pression gratuite et au pire des
cas si
Wesley arrive à tenir la position et ben
ça fera nul mais c'est un humain il peut
craquer le tournoi est long tournoi est
difficile il a beaucoup moins de temps
la pendule
si jamais où est-ce que je joue bien il
méritera la gueule mais si il joue pas
bien il va faire en fait mais la
position ici elle reste en reste pour
les blancs c'est ça qui est important de
comprendre en fait on joue pour deux
résultats
en fait
[Musique]
on a oublié
la confessionnaire de la caméra
ça fait une heure
oublié derrière donc
ouvrez vos oreilles
ouais alors je télécharge ça
il est parti
donc je vais vous envoyer le le
confection de de
Naka je vais écouter et je vais tâcher
de vous aider à traduire pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas compris tout ce que NACA
nous aurait dit il paraît qu'il parle
vite donc à tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est assez bizarre ce quand on écoute
quand on quand j'écoute
les confessions Fatou je l'entends en
double à chaque fois parce que notre
micro
sur le chat enfin sur le
twitch mais moi j'ai pas mon micro
je sais pas comment je sais pas d'où ça
vient
c'est vrai parce que moi je coupe mon
micro sur Obs pour passer
sur
mon micro
ok directement dans le micro ouvert
ok je regarderai la prochaine fois pas
tout tu as dû me dire avant je savais
pas
parce que moi j'entends je l'entends
double en fait la dernière fois aussi
bizarre bon je vais t'écouter mais des
fois je c'est chelou mais pour pour vous
faire un petit retour sur ce que n'a
qu'un droit aurait pu dire sur les
parties déjà la partie de fille roux à
niche il dit que c'est c'est
hyper standard
4,5 avec un cuto bon voilà le plein de
fois il dit que j'ai 4 c'est un petit
peu chelou mais et il est pas sûr mais
bon ok ça va
Abdou Naka donc sa partie à lui-même il
dit que bon il a parlé plein de
variantes notamment ce champion des 6
etc il a expliqué pourquoi il joue avec
ces 6 et des 5 je peux vous prêter la
position il a expliqué pourquoi il a
joué avec saisie et D5
c'est parce qu'en fait quand je vais
mettre la caméra enfin les caméras sur
les joueurs donc je parle 2
c'est la Numéro 3 et en fait il explique
pourquoi il est comme ça parce qu'il des
fois il y avait potentiellement du jeu
sur le pion des 6 expliquer plein de
fois par plein de variantes différentes
que ce pions pour être en danger et là
il a il a expliqué à la fin voyons voir
si
à
veut essayer de gagner ou si on fait nul
dans une demi-heure
il lui dit que il pense que la pollution
n'est pas grand chose et que c'est égal
et donc il dit que c'est pas impossible
qu'il fasse nul si très peu de coups
très peu de temps aussi
pour que je t'arrive il a parlé de ça ou
pas je sais même plus de quoi il a parlé
j'ai pas fait gaffe je me souviens plus
il a pas parlé je pense j'ai pas fait
gaffe
et Caro Nasso il disait que karwana
était encore dans son réparation ça se
voit même niveau du temps il dit que
faut voir si Wesley il arrive à tenir la
position ce qui est fort probable
et puis et puis voilà quoi simplement et
donc bon pas grand chose en plus je
pense que je crois qu'on a à peu près
tout dit
donc voilà c'est notre reporter
info sur place il joue le tournoi et en
plus une fois ou deux par contre et bien
un petit résumé de ce qu'il pense de
toutes les parties du tournoi une fois
ou deux ou trois
ouais
ça dépend alors c'est marrant parce que
là c'était la partie contre qui il y
avait une partie alors j'arrive plus à
me souvenir je crois que c'était contre
Paris non
il était venu au début pour faire un
petit point sur les toutes les parties
étaient revenus genre une heure après il
dit bon je m'ennuie
bon je m'ennuie maintenant je joue pas
du coup bah voilà et en fait il
est là quoi
[Musique]
en fait tout le monde le connaît vous
savez que maintenant c'est c'est un très
très grand streamer voire même le
meilleur streamer de tous les temps
d'échec et ben on voit bien que le
stream lui manque tout le temps en train
d'essayer de revenir parler à la caméra
etc il fait son petit show mais là il a
pas son ordi il a pas ses commentaires
il n'a pas sa viewers et donc bah écoute
il aime bien faire son petit truc quoi
donc voilà donc Fabi bon voilà on voit
on voit bien que au final Wesley il a
réussi à avoir setup solide et qu'il y
en a plus il a plus qu'à ramener le roi
après ça reste pas encore totalement
[Musique]
nul ou pas
moi je vais faire ça virer la tour et
essayer de de long terme je sais ça si
jamais j'arrive là je par exemple
imaginons si jamais j'arrive à jouer un
truc ce type là pour la cavaliers c'est
un petit peu bizarre mais par exemple si
jamais j'arrive à jouer un truc du style
F6 suivi droit D7 je sais pas je vais
découvrir
et plus tard et essayer de préparer ces
cinq genre voilà ça peut faire mieux
l'instant
ça peut faire nul direct parce qu'on
aura deux pions contre deux pions trois
contre trois tout à se changer
[Musique]
maintenant peut-être F6 sur F6 attention
qui est pas du cavalier 6 je pense pas
que ça soit si dangereux mais je pense
plus à ça
c'est taper sur les les pions faibles
Fatou mais à voir si vraiment il a rien
à la pression
[Musique]
en tout cas il est hyper vite
1h25 29
de jouer très vite
[Musique]
on peut revenir un peu sur un cookie
ainsi la roquette
après une longue réflexion il a fini par
faire petit rock avec les Blancs et je
vous avais dit un H4 c'est pas grave de
Rocky avec H4 les emotions fait H5 au
final la position elle est quand même
assez
tranquille il y a pas encore le feu sur
le chéquier
mais bon ça commence un peu à s'animer
on a vu le cavalier G4 qui part défendu
on a vu le cavalier là qui est pas
défendu et une tension aussi en C5 c'est
c'est ça commence à s'animer un petit
peu quand même dans la position
dans ce cas-là des petites tactiques qui
peuvent traîner
ouais
salut tout un petit mot sur les
performances de Kevin splat de France
club salut le Vince
bah écoute
il fait un super tournoi pour l'instant
j'ai pas vu ce qu'il a fait encore
aujourd'hui il avait une belle position
contre Christian Bauer c'est que moi je
suis tout je suis à l'affût le moindre
dérapage de Kevin ce sera
ce sera ce sera vu et je regarde
rapidement il a perdu ah il vient de
perdre il va me perdre contre dommage
Christian c'est un sacré adversaire
alors que Laurent alors il fait une
bonne Laurent il fait vraiment
belle saison aussi
on a déjà vu alors que barbix
il a un peu en souffrance quand même
mais c'est pas si clair c'est compliqué
la position rapidement c'était compliqué
mais nul c'était un bon résultat pour
barbix parce que si vous regardez le
match avec quatre deux pour enfin 4 2
noms il y avait 2-0 pardon
pour pour son équipe et plus que deux
parties donc en faisant nul barbarix et
ben il assure le gain de son match
donc ils font ils font une grosse saison
hein
très très grosse saison en tout cas ce
qu'ils font franchement ils ont battu
Clichy
[Musique]
c'est contre Lyon ils font ils font une
très grosse saison en tout cas ils
étaient deuxième là de leur poule avant
avant le début c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils font
alors on va revenir sur notre tournoi à
nous parce qu'on commence pas le Top 16
et salut François
il sera jamais
pas quand même pas un Barbie cela après
avoir
une deuxième norme il y a pas longtemps
pas loin du tout
et mais bon là la barbix il a
il est très très proche de son top Hello
son top hello c'est 24 70 pas mal quand
même
et je crois qu'on se donne aujourd'hui
il doit être environ à 2477 un truc
comme ça actuellement c'est pas mal
déjà
[Musique]
il faut qu'il le comprenne
alors tout est parti là il se passe pas
grand chose je pense que la partie la
plus intéressante la partie de fille ou
un je crois enfin tout ce carwana je
pense à vite se finir Abdou ça risque de
vue que ça finir aussi gokash on est là
et encore plein de choses à faire mais
fil rouge c'est vrai qu'ils roux ben
écoute c'est une partie intéressante les
deux joueurs poussent là on s'est arrêté
à un coup avec G4 il y a eu tout re 8
cavalier des deux A4 on prend l'espace
de ce côté là et sur A3 B5 les noirs qui
sont pas vraiment des cases blanches de
ce côté là après dame c'est deux
cavaliers à 5 cavaliers H4 et C5 il y a
une grosse grosse pression autant
savoir ce qu'on fait de ce centre déjà
il y a un vis-à-vis ici est-ce qu'on va
laisser le centre ouvert ce qu'on va
fermer avec dessin qu'est-ce qu'on va
manger quelque part
pas simple à toi
qu'est-ce que tu fais toi
[Musique]
je pense que il faut réagir soit tu
manges là soit tu manges là soit tu
pousses
mais pousser c'est intéressant ça prend
un cage de cavalier
de retour
prendre s'ils prendre la tour tu peux
faire F4 et jouer actif et si il prend
du pion peut-être que tu peux un jour
installe un carré en le 5 je sais pas
comment tu fais c'est peut-être un
impossible
mais
tu vois c'est deux choix différents
des deux quand même contrôler ces deux
cases là
donc moi je vois bien peut-être prise
peut-être évaluation
c'est content de manger du pion eux pour
ouvrir mon flou et mettre mon cavalier
sur la belle case 4 ça pourrait être pas
mal tout ça mais bien sûr les dents vont
jamais manger en F5
typique pour essayer un jour de faire du
G6
une fourchette ici en esquisse 5
surveillance
mais ça marche pas mal peut-être de
faire ça ça et ça
et après voir si on peut continuer à
améliorer les pièces
je mets la position de filou en fait ça
y est
c'est plutôt plaisant à regarder
donc pourquoi pas
oui
clairement
les deux joueurs veulent gagner
ça c'est cool aussi quand on est parti
comme ça ou les deux joueurs vraiment
sont là pour pour essayer de gagner
c'est cool
alors que c'est un accueil se passe pas
grand chose salut free bird
et chez Google Fatou il s'est passé un
truc
on a eu on a eu Fatou le E5 tant attendu
par tout le public
E5 jouets qui était assez logique au
final
donc le 5 c'est vraiment le coup
libérateur intéressant
mais attention
et tout le monde est content
et si je prends bah alors là
il y avait
un petit peu à tout échanger et au final
c'est noir qui ont le centre
c'est pas mal quand même pour les Noirs
il y a aussi autre chose que je voulais
dire c'est que maintenant
il y a plus qu'à aller au 5
mais bon j'ai quand même eux prendre des
cartes
ça reste d'actualité donc je vous
rappelle qu'il y a une découverte et le
cavaler ce qui va être en prise
probablement ici
donc ben écoute non compliqué
compliqué il faut que j'ai trois et quel
attention au centre et c'est en laissant
le four en jetons ici
et ben il y a toujours des idées plus
tard de faire des six si le pardon si le
pion avance en 1 4 et c'est compliqué
et tu ressens un prix toujours ça une
grosse tour une tension ensemble
enfin tout c'est une position qui me
casse critique là
hyper critique comment est-ce qu'on joue
là
comment est-ce qu'on joue
rien manger là je peux manger là je peux
manger là je vais bouger mon cavalier il
y a plein plein de possibilités là
c'est pas de quoi prendre en fait c'est
ça qui me dérange je sais pas de quoi
prendre
c'est pas trop quoi penser
c'est pas clair
sur le long terme
je sais pas si tu as vraiment le choix
ouais mais quand tu prends de E
ça te fait une structure assez pourri
quand même
toujours ça en prise aussi c'est
compliqué en fait
c'est compliqué pour les deux joueurs et
on a l'impression en fait que tout va
bien mais au final il y a un peu tout en
prise quoi ça peut être un truc
d'hypnose salut Alicia salut salut à
tous alors
donc
1600 que tu dois battre pour obtenir ton
titre t'as pas peur que ce soit un
dingue qui joue contre toi genre que en
particulier avec des j'aime
si la ça sent
particulièrement mais bon ça reste un
donc quand même je regarde sont quand
même relativement bonnes
après bon bah vous savez on n'a jamais
allé à l'abri moi je peux faire une
mauvaise partie il faut faire une bonne
partie on n'est pas à l'abri mais bon
écoute
je sais pas quoi je sais pas quoi te
répondre déjà si il est espagnol c'est
bon signe
s'il iranien ou
chinois ou indien c'est un peu moins bon
signe
mais bon on verra on sait pas mais après
un moment donné pour moi
je prends pas quelqu'un qui a un point
non mais en fait moi je veux je veux
aussi gagner une tournoi je vais arriver
je vais je vais
et puis un moment donné le titre il faut
le mériter aussi après ok même si la
rondin je parle je prends un 1600 il y a
plein de gens il y a plein de gens qui
peuvent dire oui bon il prend 1600 pour
gagner son titre on peut penser comme ça
mais au final j'ai quand même
[Musique]
ça fait ça fait ça fait quand même des
années des années que que je tourne
autour de 2004
un moment donné il faut il faut aller
dans les mains
mais c'est vrai que j'ai refusé des
parties j'aurais pu jouer avoir joué
avant
mais il y avait la Ligue des Canaries là
qui me posait de jouer il y avait des
grands mettre à jouer et tout j'ai dit
non il manque un point c'est pas ça quoi
donc je suis parti et non je n'irai pas
jouer
[Musique]
après si j'avais un contrat de parti que
je devais jouer parce que je t'ai payé
et cetera oui je suis allé et comme je
jouais bénévolement
moi aussi je peux le faire
[Musique]
le si tu es sur une carte c'est gagné
Gibraltar
et je vais manger un chi un film ça va
mais Gibraltar ouais c'est il y a un
gros tournoi qui organisait chaque année
je crois que c'est le mois de janvier il
me semble et c'est un tournoi qui est
qui est
qui est hyper hyper fort je me souviens
que de un an à l'avance s'inscrivait
pour l'année d'après
c'était ouf
300 personnes max à chaque fois et c'est
un tournoi où c'est un open c'est un
open ou viennent des joueurs comme
Nakamura quoi donc évidemment que le
niveau est extrêmement fort tout le
monde veut venir jouer et souvent si je
suis invitation et les prix c'était la
folie genre il y avait des pré féminins
aussi et je crois que le enfin il y
avait toutes les meilleures choses du
monde qui venaient parce que le premier
prix féminin je crois que c'est un truc
de style
je sais plus
mais c'est le style 20 ou 30 000 euros
le premier prix de l'Open je sais plus
comment c'était mais c'était peut-être
200000 euros enfin c'était énorme mais
le féminin à 20000 euros donc oui fan
qui venait il y avait les mositchoucs
tout le monde quoi donc c'était pas de
blague quoi là c'était attention 20 000
balles sur un tournoi
ça commence à faire
tu sais pourquoi tu es là après pour les
les gros règles comme tu peux avoir tu
peux avoir les Nakamura les mvl tu avais
toujours de l'or comme ça qu'il est top
alors ils vend chouk tu avais toujours
comme ça qui venait
donc pour eux c'est un peu normal de
d'avoir ces prix là dans leur tournoi
qui joue mais quand tu es une femme
c'est pas tous les jours que tu as un
tournoi à 20 000 au premier tu vois
c'est pas tous les jours quand même
donc évidemment que c'était le
rendez-vous de l'année
et toi tu as vu ça
je pouvais pas le faire parce que je
travaillais tout le temps cette période
de l'année et puis et puis voilà je sais
même plus si ton mari il se tient encore
je sais même plus mais moi j'étais allé
avec ma famille mais il y a les il y a
longtemps il y a des années on avait
fait un petit stop
pour moi
mais j'aimerais trop aimé un tournoi
comme ça un open aussi fort c'est génial
c'est à dire que tu joues peut-être non
mais la ronde un en fait
2400 hello là on a tout à l'heure quoi
en fait que je te parle quoi enfin c'est
génial en fait trop bien tu as trop de
souvenirs en fait
trop de souvenirs j'avais vu je crois il
y avait Nakamura
sur twitch
et
elle avait une position complètement
gagnante
3 ou 4 pions de plus je me sens cette un
truc de fou je crois
et c'était fait complètement volé
c'était trop triste pour elle
vous imaginez Batna Camorra c'est ce
monstre gypse sûrement j'essaie je sais
pas ouvrir le lien à ça c'est ça va être
ça c'était vraiment le tournoi de
l'année et je crois que que
les inscriptions étaient clos close une
année à l'avance
genre ça c'était ouf quoi
je sais pas les dates mais je crois que
c'était genre en janvier et tu sais que
janvier
2020 tu t'inscris pour janvier 2021 quoi
voilà donc c'est marrant quoi
va rester ici et si jamais elle est
noire un jour décide de devenir capturer
ce cavalex fou et ben je reprendrai et
je perdrai un pion mais j'aurais ouvert
les 15 blanches et il y a aussi lui
emprise enfin tout le temps plus tard
donc en fait c'est ça va être ça va être
sympa je pense qu'il y a deux grandes
chances qu'un moment donné
mais qui l'ouvre les cases blanches
d'une certaine manière et ça peut être
pas mal du tout pour
pour les blancs tout ça
donc moi j'ai parié nul enfin tout mais
je suis un peu déçu j'aime beaucoup la
position de Google je trouve que c'est
une position qui est extrêmement dur à
jouer pour le noir qui peut se passer
plein plein plein de choses sur le
centre notamment avec la paire de fou
et après un peu de développement il y a
des grandes questionnements sur le
centre est-ce qu'il y avait des qui qui
est vraiment embêtant quoi
doivent
tout tenir
presque sur un fil
le cavalier C6 quand je dis bon il peut
tomber on aura envie qu'il tombe pour un
chez le noir parce que il est quand même
assez assez gênant mais dans ce cas là
on a aussi G4 potentiellement récupérés
en tout cas il y a des problèmes pour
les noirs
à récupérer j'ai les cases blanches qui
est dans un autre moyen toi si tu es fou
parle tu es content
une belle paire de fou
donc c'est une partie qui va être animée
et je pense que là on a deux parties
animées c'est celle là donc Google je
t'arrive et on va avoir aussi un
fil rouge à Liri qui va être aussi animé
et par contre
Naka Fatou je vois pas trop ça continuer
ça fait un moment que ça tourne un petit
peu
[Musique]
il a dit on va voir si
Abdou veut faire un nul rapide ou pas
bon c'est pas son genre mais en fait il
pensait en disant ça il pensait que ça
pouvait s'échanger assez rapidement par
exemple je sais pas genre ça ça
tu vois ça peut échanger relativement
vite quoi
après bon bah la position elle est quand
même plus ou moins agate peut-être les
blancs sont un peu mieux parce qu'ils
ont le fou qui qui est plus fort que que
le foie de verse donc voilà
donc peut-être que ça peut le faire tu
mets un fond un V3 tu joues 5 dames
peut-être qu'il y a moyen de pouvoir un
tout petit peu ta pression mais bon
parce que donc avoir en tout cas on peut
s'attendre à une nulle mais ça va jouer
ouais ça va jouer encore et par contre
carwana so Fatou et ben j'ai
l'impression que ils font le plan qu'on
avait proposé tout à l'heure
regarde il a joué F6 il a mis le roi là
comme on l'avait dit la chasse et la
tour ici et maintenant
il vient de vous cabaliser 5 et ici je
pense que cavaler des 7 6 8 c'est 5
était peut-être la menace des noirs pour
tout échanger
5 qui attaque le petit pion qui a eu à 5
et maintenant est-ce qu'on peut espérer
donc il y a quand même et chaque ca va
les prendre à 5 plateaux
pas mal de choses en prise je peux venir
ici
et là enfin tout
est-ce que tu veux
tu peux te le permettre
là
je crois pas
ah peut-être jusqu'à valait ces quatre
Fatou
on sacrifie un deuxième pion mais
la tour en prenant à deux
faut vraiment cette finale peut-être
qu'elle est juste nulle
peut-être ça mon prochain coup
peut-être même d'abord avant de faire
ces 6 peut-être
par exemple
tu fais chèque je reviens là j'attaque
le
tu l'as reculer et je fais ça ça peut
être une nulle possible il y a un pion
de plus pour les blancs mais en fait je
suis paralysé
et si je viens comme ça ben j'ai perdu
ça c'est intéressant du coup c'était
ligne avec C4 et je pense à ce que c'est
la vie
je prends juste là et bon plus les pions
s'échangent plus ça peut faire nul et
sans cavaler ses quatre caisse et 4
images de manger là c'est qu'elle bouge
je prends enfin je prends pas mais
peut-être juste ça
oups
presque pas vu la fourchette mais j'ai
vu la jauge monter d'un coup un vrai que
nous on n'a pas la jauge
on fait son jauge mais
c'est un coup comme cavale C5 pour
empêcher
l'ordinateur on essaie de réfléchir un
petit peu et c'est vrai qu'en fait
nous ça nous fait travailler aussi le
fait de pas avoir l'évaluation de
l'ordinateur ça nous force un petit peu
à
travers un peu les échecs essayer de
voir ce qui se passe et vous vous avez
aussi un petit peu on va dire notre
évaluation c'est mieux que plutôt que de
lire un ordinateur ça tout le monde peut
le faire
de lire l'ordinateur c'est trop facile
mais nous on veut vous montrer un petit
peu comment comment nous on réfléchit
après tu finis avec un pion de plus de
côté roi est-ce que ça peut être un plan
pour annuler quand même
[Musique]
de quelle ligne cette partie là je pense
pas ah tu parles la partie de de
Google
mais en fait juste
là si je mange de quatre avec foie dame
juste pour voir la partie
en fait allez juste sans calculer
d'accord je vais juste jouer un coup
juste pour voir
allez si on veut celle-là
salut à toi
genre celle-là oui il peut faire nul
derrière moi peut-être mais bon bah j'ai
aussi de quoi attaquer en fait la
position est ouverte il y a plein de
choses
il y a encore beaucoup de jeux quoi il y
a encore plein de choses à faire c'est
pas sûr du tout que ça peut faire nul la
partie
où il y a cavalier qui empêche mais je
peux je peux bouger ma dame avant et ça
reste pas si simple encore une fois donc
là déjà
mais juste pour faire exprès je suis
cavalier FX maintenant je peux bouger
madame il y aura ça en lierre j'ai
toujours lié de faire un jour H5
et il y a une pression au centre ça peut
être nul bien sûr mais ça peut toujours
être jouable parce que le Renoir et le
canal un peu plus faible donc ça pas du
tout plaire
après bien sûr j'ai fait un coup à 4
juste pour passer mon tour là ça mois de
Joyeuse le droit de faire un bon coup
quand
je sais pas ce que je peux faire
d'ailleurs oui oui je pense que je vais
essayer de faire un coup qui est mieux
que
A4 bien entendu
mais bon
mais c'est pas compliqué j'ai du mal à
évaluer la position en fait
un coup à faire
tu vois là je pensais à ça
la jauge qui
elle passe un peu quand même
non mais en fait pourquoi ce 4 parce que
lui il est un peu hors-jeu je veux
ouvrir mon four
il a des problèmes
mais par exemple tu prends là j'ai
et là je commence à avoir un pied
peut-être les choses si tu prends pas tu
manges genre là peut-être je peux manger
à l'intermédiaire un peu le même genre
je fais ça et
je commence à m'activer il y a aussi il
faut prendre les quatre en fait la
pollution un peu partie bon il reste une
fourchette mais la partie elle veut
partir en live très très vite quoi
sur ça prise prise prise tu as pris un
pion et ben écoute ce purge je m'en fous
moi je vais ouvrir les case blanche
et je prends ici ici ou peut-être que je
vais vous dire pour jouer des cinq
peut-être que je peux prendre la qualité
là-haut peut-être que je récupère juste
le Cavaillon j'ai quatre je sais pas
mais en fait les cases blanches sont
sont faibles la position elle est pas
simple du tout et bon coup cash c'est
très créatif c'est un excellent genre
d'échec
il va il va savoir quoi faire
il va essayer de trouver de meilleur
coup je vais mettre l'ordi va tout juste
je vais je suis curieux voir ce qu'il
pense
bah c'est pas logique
donc E4 bon c'est un coup qui est
compliqué parce que il faut calculer
tout mais dans l'idée ouvrir le fout de
case blanche c'est normal
ce qui nous manque
on sait que les Blancs ont un problème
sur que les Noirs ont un problème sur
casse blanche donc c'est logique de
vouloir ouvrir les cadranche maintenant
et ben il faut voir comment parce que
concrètement c'est pas simple quoi il y
a des
il y a plein de décisions à prendre il
faut calculer un peu tout parce que
quand tu fais ces quatre on a dit il y a
ça il y a ça il y a ça il y a ça il y a
plein de co-candidats pour les Noirs
quand tu fais E4 pareil il y a ça il y a
ça il y a ça il y a plein de candidats
donc peu importe ce que tu choisis de
faire c'est chaud
donc ouais voilà
c'est plus compliqué avec hasard c'est
quand même assez solide
c'est quand même eux qui poussent sur
case noire
donc ouais c'est la partie intéressante
carvana et Filou ça veut partir en l'air
d'ailleurs regarde Fatou carolasso
exactement ce qu'on avait dit
ils font exactement ce qu'on avait dit
et sur cavalier C4 et bien sur cavalier
français 4 on va voir pion français 4 et
là ça va faire nul dans quelques coups
en fait ça va pas traîner
ça a pas traîné et
Nakamura ça échange aussi
la caméra ça change
tour évite prise donc là il va manger
j'imagine de la tour parce qu'il veut
quand même échanger les pièces vu qu'il
y avait ça pourrait être pas bête pourra
prévenir en D6 et de dire sur ce case là
mais de la tour bon ben il a compris
qu'il voulait changer ça
je pense pas tout ça va faire nul très
très vite
je vois pas trop
ils vont me donner raison
en plus en plus bon je sais que c'est un
grand bâton de
mais bon il fait un tournoi difficile
donc ce qui veut c'est faire prise prise
est tombé peut-être et un truc comme ça
intéressant en tout cas très intéressant
le couper 5
de Abdou
et est-ce qu'on va assister à un
cavalier
pour échanger
les pièces
je veux tout changer
qu'est-ce que je veux
je mange hein
c'est pas laquelle tu veux prendre mais
je prendrai le fou
moi je suis comme ça
il est fort non je pense qu'il faut que
tu prends la cavalier
parce que maintenant quand tu bouges ton
fou et ben je vais j'ai dû B6 puis ou
même du A6 en fait je pense que je peux
te casser la structure là
je m'aime
que je te pose des problèmes quand même
ça c'est clair
pas mal
et après peut-être que je peux jouer
autre chose que
d'être préparé ça c'est que ça ça c'est
embêtant
en fait tu es juste tu dis
[Musique]
il a fait il a fait presque souffrant OK
tac la tour qui va bouger la tour en
priori
quoi
ok mais bon je pense pas je vois pas
trop quelque chose
Fatou qui s'est passé aussi ce qu'on
avait dit regarde il a mangé
il a joué et il a joué un petit peu
voilà
c'est très positionnel ce qui se passe
là
c'est très positionnel
tu peux encore faire ton petit ton petit
cours bonne pièce mauvaise pièce
comment tu le mets
du rouge à 7
ça me suffit
et après je mets du vert sur
sur les autres fous
sur le four
il est un petit peu triste
c'est pas ouvert pour lui
du petit verre pour ton cavalier ton
joli cavalier
je pense que toutes les pièces sont
bonnes derrière
tout le monde ouvert
si bien placé
ou pas non oui non ça pas trop
mais le cavalier à 5 maintenant qu'on a
juste 4 il peut aussi le demander 4 tu
vois
donc faut voir mais après si moi je
prends là et que je veux mon cavalence
aussi c'est pas mal chacun à ces cases
tout ça c'est intéressant
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand tu as
été fait pour pour je contre lui et
essayer d'ouvrir là et peut-être même un
jour au cinéma ouvrir ça fout aussi
toi c'est assez profond je pense
intéressant
mais en tout cas c'est une grosse partie
là il y a plein de décisions à prendre
et il se passe plein de choses donc ça
peut faire nul bien évidemment comme ça
peut gagner mais là on va voir une
partie qui va durer
parce qu'il va durer il y a encore plein
de choses à faire il a pris
ça me paraît bien
noir un petit peu tout seul
oui tu peux encore jouer ça après faut
voir un peu ce que je vais faire parce
que ça c'est un plan qu'on peut faire H4
G3 H4 G5 en préparant et tout mais
est-ce que c'est vraiment là que je veux
faire mon plan là après mon roi il est
quand même sacrément faible aussi
et puis les Noirs aussi de l'autre côté
il commence à pousser à essayer d'ouvrir
je peux pas toujours facilement
pousser mais bon si c'était plus calme
de la dame du côté de la dame je
pourrais faire dame de tranquillement H4
je pourrais essayer de ramener mesdames
mes pièces attaquer quoi mais là c'est
quand même un petit peu compliqué de ce
côté là
donc je peux pas partir faire
complètement allé de ce côté là
parce que c'est assez c'est assez ouvert
quand même
donc c'est 4 c'est la partie 4
et la maintenant on risque de voir
sûrement un carré
par la suite qu'elle va les prendre
qu'elle va les prendre dans
pourquoi fleurir
pourquoi est-ce qu'il réfléchit je sais
pas
j'ai laissé la clé sur la porte d'entrée
du rentrer à la maison je vais l'enlever
j'arrive
[Musique]
comme ça
elle a récupéré
avec le fou
en tout cas avoir une vue de dessus
mon cavalier prend
sens voilà
il faut faire quand même pas mal de
choses
un Fatou j'ai
un professionnel des carreaux
je me méfie
bah oui il fait souvent norvégien
alors tu sais que tu sais que hier je me
suis rendu compte pas tout
je connais quelqu'un qui
qui aurait pu le traduire en norvégien
incroyable
et il m'a dit oui je t'ai vu etc
[Musique]
et du coup du coup il m'a dit qu'il
parle pas
couramment mais en fait il parle suédois
il m'a dit des fois ça ressemble un peu
et caractère je le comprends bien je dis
bon écoute alors si tu veux on va
essayer de regarder de regarder un peu
les deux vidéos qu'on a et
[Musique]
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe parce
que là il se passe pas grand chose tout
à l'heure enfin tout qu'est-ce qu'on
fait une petite pause
tu fais une pause
[Musique]
et
puis je vous garde ça pour le retour
quand même j'ai envie de voir ce qui se
passe
donc je télécharge tout et je vous donne
un peu ça après voilà et non parfois un
petit pause parce qu'il faut s'hydrater
comme ça tout nous le signal et on vient
du 5 minutes à tout de suite à tout de
suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec Fatou
salut Yumé dans le chat
nous avons nous avons du coup à vous
montrer on nous avait promis les
confessions de Nakamura et de 45 Fatou
on va commencer par celle de Nakamura si
vous voulez comme ça que ça sera plus
celle de Carsen c'est de 45
n'est pas sur soi en anglais ou pas
alors partons
en fait
cette vidéo Fatou et ben on l'avait déjà
écouté c'était sauf que là ils ont
rajouté un échec qui est à l'analyse
pour qu'on suivre pour qu'on puisse
suivre plus facilement donc je voulais
l'épargner donc maintenant je vous enfin
on va découvrir ensemble si vous voulez
la vidéo de Magnus
Magnus qui nous a fait voilà je sais pas
en quelle langue c'est
espérons que soit en anglais
qui est malheureusement c'est en
norvégien je vais écrire à mon ami
est-ce que tu es pas loin
je vais lui demander peut-être qu'il est
pas loin
alors où es-tu
sur WhatsApp
voilà
je viens de lui écrire à l'instant
pour voir si il va me répondre
je sais qu'il est assez occupé en ce
moment donc je sais pas du tout si
il va pouvoir nous répondre mais dans
tous les cas
[Musique]
on va voir
ok Fatou donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pendant notre absence on a eu des
échanges en C4 ah il m'a équipé il va me
répondre il est là
il est là
il est là tu es là ok donc tu nous
écoutes bien sur le chat peut-être déjà
mais il nous parle pas sur le chat
je lui réponds quand même
que
ce qu'il a sur le chat
ben écoutez Magnus en
norvégien il peut nous traduire
incroyable
et ça c'est une prouesse les gars parce
que norvégien c'est pas évident
il y a pas la même racine que
ce que nous on connaît un fantôme
ouais et ben écoutez on va essayer de
faire confiance à grondade et on va
écouter
voilà on va d'abord lui dire bonjour le
remercier et on va essayer de de
balancer la vidéo de Carlson pour voir
si il peut ou pas nous traduire
je crois qu'on entend pas Fatou les gens
ils disent effectivement ça touche je
l'avais mieux parce qu'elle parlait trop
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
sur une autre scène parce que je pensais
que c'était que le son venait de micro
que je t'avais mis
un problème ça ne vient pas de moi c'est
ça allez
comment je peux rester une autre sinon
on peut te mettre ta photo et puis on
regarde parler c'est marrant allez on va
on va envoyer le professionnel de Carsen
en norvégien et on va espérer gros dinde
puisse nous traduire un petit peu tout
ça
et je crois qu'elle avait dit en plus
elle est assez longue donc mais bon le
message général ça me va très très bien
allez merci à tout de suite
[Musique]
alors j'attends
la réponse de Grenade en espérant alors
moi j'ai rien compris du coup Fatou
on a compris contrôle
donc voilà je sais pas si mon gros dalle
je pense qu'il va être en train d'écrire
je sais pas si là je pense que la cam du
comprend quelques trucs parce qu'il m'a
dit qu'il comprend généralement un petit
peu mais il a peut-être pas comprendre
compris à 100% mais si c'est déjà du 50%
c'est pas mal déjà
même s'il a pas compris il peut inventer
personne ne pourra le contredire
que Carlsen dit que
faire c'est incroyable on va y croire
en même temps c'est le cas évidemment
attends il me semble Fatou que que
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé pendant
ce temps là
za qui est sacrifie une qualité et
pourquoi ça fait une quinté enfin tout
juste
c'était pas forcé hein
il y a des gens qui viennent parler ce
matin
je suis associable
j'aurais pu parce que là sur dame C2 et
ben on se prend un fou B3 on perd la
qualité c'est 3 on se prend un tour B3
ça lui a dit
et il a dû juger que c'était bien de
donner la qualité
[Musique]
non mais en fait je pense qu'il veut pas
subir
je trouve que c'est assez
c'est assez après bon mais il a quand
même passé
il faut toujours voir les compensations
quand on donne quelque chose il faut
voir donc là le petit pion a du mal j'ai
un peu du mal à les comprendre je
t'avoue
j'ai un peu de mal comprendre
enfin tout
j'ai pensé aussi pourquoi est-ce que la
jauge je pense aussi et
pourquoi la jauge je ne sais pas
pourquoi là
[Musique]
ouais peut-être
moi aussi
j'ai mis mon passé ok bon en tout cas
intéressant un jeu qui trouve que c'est
intéressant mais
voilà c'est vrai
une info dans l'oreillette qui me dit
que l'Armageddon entre carwala et sceaux
commencera à 20h10
donc ce qui signifie que la partie était
terminée
pourquoi c'était plus tendu en classique
et plus facile en magasin penser être un
total contrôle puis il a eu un problème
de temps je crois il n'a pas plus
d'explications en classe qu'actuellement
je vais faire insister et il a un peu
refusé de répondre il a dit je veux pas
en dire plus et plusieurs fois on verra
bien sinon il adore les commentaires de
stouf et cherche le 06 de Fatou
merci beaucoup en tout cas grenade pour
ton message
si tu veux gros dinde tu peux alors je
t'enverrai en privé le numéro de Fatou
tu tu essaieras de transmettre à ma
Magnus si tu peux et je suis sûr que ça
je suis sûr que ça n'ira pas mal tout
et
puis et puis moi bon je je
comprends qu'il est bien mes
commentaires c'est tout à fait naturel
c'est tout ce que à
chaque fois
il a changé de tête ça veut dire qu'on a
pas oui on a pas remis les bons noms sur
les bonnes têtes
c'est dommage que je puisse pas que je
puisse pas bloquer les gens sur Youtube
parce qu'il y a des gens qui qui sont là
mais entre bande pourquoi on peut pas y
passer
juste viennent tirer leur haine sur les
réseaux au lieu juste de se taire des
fois ça donne envie de
bref
il y a des gens qui sont
qui ont envie toujours de mal se
comporter qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
te dise
donc la même partie à l'écran oui non là
je suivais quand je suis revenu de de
du comment dire de la vidéo de Magnus et
ben je suis sur la mauvaise sur la
mauvaise fenêtre
voilà
non mais c'est très bien quand tu as
franchement ton ton ton
[Musique]
résumé super bien en tout cas merci à
toi là c'est déjà très bien c'est vrai
que Magnus souvent quand il a des
problèmes enfin quand il ça se passe pas
bien ou quoi
dans un tournoi ou bah il aime souvent
pas en parler il dit ouais non on verra
après ouais non mais je crois en parler
et des fois il y a des questions
gênantes c'est les journalistes ils
adorent tout ce qui est gênant en fait
et plein de fois en fait et ben plein de
fois en fait et ben il envoie un peu
chier entre guillemets les journalistes
et genre je plains du monde par exemple
ma vue si il blender et on va demander
pourquoi tu as blender mais juste laisse
tranquille quoi enfin tu vois et en fait
il cherche souvent la petite bête etc et
c'est vrai que ça c'est typique
c'est normal de gardien de répondre un
peu à côté de lui dire voilà mais en
tout cas merci pour ton pour ton résumé
et ta traduction c'était cool donc voilà
ça c'est la partie
oui non bien sûr voilà il a pas envie de
parler de tout ça quoi faites juste
[Musique]
tout simplement
il fait un mauvais tournoi c'est la vie
peut-être qu'il a des problèmes perso à
côté enfin c'est pas un moment donné ça
ça regarde pas forcément le le les gens
enfin juste donc il a raison de pas
s'étaler
cette situation là hop c'est la partie
tout aussi ce qui empêche du coup on
retrouve aussi ce qui vient défendre le
cavalier F6 qui veut dire que maintenant
car elle est prend H6 je prends est un
point abscisse n'est plus possible après
tout aussi
damacat4 tours en V2
alors Magnus il a fait il a perdu la
ronde un contre karwana et après c'est
que des nuls après les armage donc il a
gagné etc voilà mais en partie classique
qu'il est pas il est pas en forme
en tout cas en particulier classique
bon c'est le joueur qui est le plus fort
du tournoi clairement ce champion
du monde numéro un mondial etc
et en fait tout simplement
c'est un tournoi oui bah hyper 16 points
c'est mon string c'est énorme enfin tout
ce qui perd donc c'est vraiment pour lui
un très mauvais temps
mais bon bah écoute c'est la vie tu peux
pas toujours être en forme avec du rates
il va faire des tournois seulement quand
il est vraiment
le fait que ce soit à domicile c'est un
petit peu son
[Musique]
un petit peu le tournoi pas manquer
c'est la star locale
alors que qui était pas en forme aussi
on sait pas
moi je ne sais pas je sais pas ce qui
est exactement comme tu dis à sa vie sa
vie perso qui peut jouer bon bah c'est
pas grave il se refera ailleurs
[Musique]
bienvenue à toi salut à tous et donc ok
donc là bon parti je pense que Firo il
est très mal en train de partir
qui aurait finalement mal on voit qu'il
a pas bien
gérer cette phase de milieu de jeu avec
la poussée noire en B5
et
j'arrive je te fais du mal quand même
enfin tout à trouver le contre jeu
Dali raisin dans cette partie parce que
là on avait parlé du cavalier fromage si
ça avait été un pronostic
et là et ben écoute j'ai beaucoup de mal
à trouver je pensais à fouet fin c'est 4
éventuellement
et donc donc voilà il faut C4 un
contrôle qui pourrait être faire sens en
tout cas
ce fou qui pourrait être force à
diagonale vous savez que ici des Blancs
ont la paire de fou des noirs n'ont pas
le foot car blanche donc en l'absence ça
vous casse blanche on va jouer sur la
couleur que n'a pas les Noirs donc ici
ça fait sens de mettre le flou sur casse
blanche mais bon est-ce que ça va
suffire moi je peux jouer tomber tomber
si ton V1 changer les tours je vois pas
trop trop où vais en venir à lireza
enfin tout j'ai un peu peur
je te comprends c'est
une grande décision qui l'a prise en
laissant la qualité
et il arrive peut-être pas à démontrer
qu'il a raison
non mais bon c'est logique en fait de
jeux sur la maintenant qu'il a il a peur
de la qualité mais il a mangé
cadenge maintenant son foot
non si je mets des couleurs sur mes fous
sur mes pièces c'est trois bonnes pièces
mais j'ai une qualité de moi
donc en fait peut-être que ben si jamais
j'arrive à faire ça
à échanger une pièce imagine on regarde
si jamais j'arrive le fond noir
s'activait déjà
vide va faire ça
a échanger peut-être le fou contre le
cavalier et à mettre un fond en dessin
ou mon cavalier qui va venir en a cinq
j'ai un certain contre jeu parce que
j'ai un fou qui est hyper central qui a
une belle diagonale sur le roi le
foulard est mauvais etc peut-être pas
mal
par contre par contre
ici
et ben j'ai quand même qui était moins
donc tombé 6 tempête qui arrive et c'est
assez compliqué
donc
voilà pas terrible
alors on avait dit 20h10 pour le
l'Armageddon c'est ça on n'est pas en
retard on ira voir un magasin de
Caravana contre le sauts
on a un petit peu abandonné
depuis un petit moment
ouais c'est la partie numéro 4
et ouh là là c'est c'est marrant la
position
c'est vraiment la position
alors on s'est arrêté je sais plus trop
où il y a une dame de 6
4 on avance qu'il allait jouer et c'est
4 c'est le coup d'ailleurs je me rends
compte que je voulais pas le mettre je
vais regarder après tout à l'heure
et ici c'est 4
[Musique]
puissance 4 écoute je me laisse je me
lève de gagner
après F4
ouais et en fait alors E4 c'est c'est un
coup qui qui paraît bizarre parce que là
on peut tous manger de tout dans tous
les sens mais ce qui est hyper important
de voir être comprendre c'est que je
menace avec mes deux pions de mangeant
des cinq
et si je me rendais 5
E4 ou C4 là par contre tu menaces aussi
de pousser c'est ça aussi dangereux en
fait ce qui est très important de manger
ce pion parce que après j'aurai un peu
enfin mon pion qui est passé ce serait
défendu par un pion ça c'est important
et si tu prends un des pions genre je
suis là il vient de nous dire que je
descends et là j'ai deux pions passés
quoi et bien sûr j'aurais sûrement mais
j'espère plus tard récupérer un petit
pion quoi
donc mais avec ça en tout cas je suis
assez content j'ai des pions qui a un
petit qui qui sont passés qui avance
quand même assez cool pour moi j'ai la
paire de fou encore ce serait vraiment
sympa donc c'est pas c'est quoi sur le 4
cavaler prendre un 4
et l'appendais 5 waouh moi j'aurais dit
ça ça et ça qui avait la logique enfin
tout
mais non non
les bailles exactement sur ça parce
qu'il te faut F3 je suis cavaler prend
le 4 mais c'est la partie
merci beaucoup Hélène pour pour ton raid
merci à toi de faire un petit saut
merci pour ton rêve tortue
ou pas encore le stream de notre cher
Hélène qui adore d'ailleurs vous savez
ça ne deuxième passion après les échecs
c'est c'est le chorizo alors ça c'est ça
le dit pas trop généralement mais ok
pour ceux qui la connaissent un peu
mieux en tout cas
souvenez-vous si vous avez un cadeau à
lui faire ou quoi la petite
bref du coup voilà elle a une chaîne
Youtube et aussi une chaîne twitch
n'hésitez pas à la suivre sur ces
réseaux et
à lui rappeler tout ça
donc elle a fini son stream je sais pas
ce qu'elle a fait aujourd'hui Eden comme
activité sur son stream
on fait de la pub quand même la pub
après
il faut
non elle est adorable très gentille
donc là on a la configuration des des
deux pions passées liés mais alors du
coup c'est quoi la différence Fatou
entre
cette position qu'on a ici la différence
et la position
ok bon j'ai la en fait la différence
c'est que
on a échangé ça et ça
et la dame elle est ici
donc la différence c'est que et c'est
vrai je pense que ça sonne avantage et
Google c'est que la position elle est
ouverte
et comme la position elle est ouverte
parce qu'il manque des pions et ben des
fous lanceront plus actifs
je pensais d'accord pas toi là si jamais
j'arrive à jouer à foue F3 et à pousser
là mais fou ils vont directement être
trop forts
on peut bouger les pièces comparé les
deux positions et là on voit
effectivement que
les fous prennent totalement vie dans
cette variante là
une Copa alors sec là d'ailleurs on dit
la Coop encore ça c'est vrai que la
charcuterie corse elle est je sais pas
tu as goûté Fatou
mais c'est juste génial
je compare oui bon goûter mais je
comparerai pas ça que tu as raison quand
même parce que mais c'est quand même
très très bon ah oui c'est
ce que tu connais
c'est meilleur que le chorizo
je connais pas mais priori
mais c'est vrai que c'est à la base je
suis quand même pas trop trop
charcuterie quand même à la base mais
alors ça encore c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois que j'y allais c'était
j'allais au marché le matin pas le matin
il y a toujours un petit marche sur la
place de Bastia là
place de Bastia je crois que là comment
s'appelle la place Saint-Nicolas je
crois
c'est c'est génial moi je fais plein de
fois encore pour jouer ton il y a
à thé de Bastien ok bah oui
j'ai joué ah oui j'ai joué je ne sais
pas combien de fois
les tournois à Bastia
c'est facile aussi
mais je ne sais pas je suis en 90 qui
est au hasard donc
du coup j'étais pas dans
90 mais je suis allé plein de fois à
Bastia le tournoi qui se joue au théâtre
au théâtre mais
et ouais c'est en fait
la lique Corse des échecs a fait
énormément pour les échecs
en Corse et
pas qu'en Corse d'ailleurs enfin si tu
vois encore mais il y a eu pas mal de
choses et franchement c'est
[Musique]
tout le monde se connaît là-bas
mais en vrai c'est cool moi je suis allé
plein de fois encore j'ai jamais
regretté mes voyages c'est toujours trop
cool on reste sur trois sympas et puis
les gens sont vraiment sympa en plus
là-bas
c'est toujours bien accueilli
franchement c'est j'ai très très bonne
très bon souvenir de tout mon temps que
j'ai fait encore
et tout le monde même tous les
ordinateurs là-bas sont géniaux sont
très très sympas
ou alors en tout cas bonjour à tous les
corps qui nous regardent
et la maman de malin en plus aussi
à la coque pour
pour
un jour on se verra avec une alerte
tu me la garde
ton Caval et F6 fou F3
et ici là il tape D4 qui va arriver
alors Dame des quatre j'ai peut-être
tout droit enfin tout en fait on donne
des quatre je prends la dame je crois et
scorpion prend alors là c'est ça va être
la poussée des pions
est-ce que cette tient en ta faveur
d'échanger
E4 alors oui
ça tue un peu mon fou mais il faut voir
comment tu gères ça pour récupérer
des cinq
en plus c'est jouer vite et sur 4
est-ce que tu t'en fous complètement
insiste peut-être
comme ça
deux pions soutenu par le fou enfin
c'est un cauchemar
ouais c'est foutu tu vois j'avais dit la
position il y avait eu pas beaucoup de
coups ce qui est tellement tellement
compliqué là quand on est à prix B4 non
c'est même après E5 tellement compliqué
cette position j'avais dit que ça
pouvait fermer très vite en fait parce
que c'est hyper compliqué
et Ariane qui a fait une erreur qui a
fait les DF6 qui
humainement a l'air assez naturel tout
mais je pense qu'il a vu pas dû voir un
4 je pense qu'il a raté le 4 et
et après le 4 en fait
c'est c'est juste c'est juste foutu je
crois en fait je crois que c'est perdu
mais c'est ouf
très mal
c'est dur à
c'est dur à jouer le 4
enfin je veux dire c'est hyper joli tu
vois tu as jamais vu une partie comme ça
quoi trois contre trois tu as
l'impression qu'on joue pas de chèque
qu'on joue à tu vois c'est marrant quoi
tu peux pas faire ça c'est pas jouer au
hasard c'est pas jouer au hasard c'est
très précis et
c'est beau
c'est encore plus beau non franchement
c'est ce que nous fait Google c'est
vraiment génial et en plus tu as parlé
sur Google donc je te fais des sites
Fatou évidemment merci
Salut à tous
qu'est-ce que tu veux un panier n'hésite
pas à m'envoyer ton adresse j'ai une
source qui fait c'est à charcuterie ou
d'accord et ben écoute
et ben écoute tu vois tenir au courant
mais moi aussi je connais enfin j'ai des
gens sur Facebook qui qui
[Musique]
fait son marché
alors je sais pas comment ça se passe
exactement mais je crois qu'ils ont leur
fermer tout à ceux qui font tout en fait
faire attention alors tac
abdounaka on peut le voir un peu ce qui
se passe si tu veux faire
un tour il nous reste trois parties
attends on a pas loupé le
bravo on a
loupé on est pile à l'heure c'était pas
il y a 4 minutes
alors oui donc là c'est Armageddon on
est en 7 minutes pour les Noirs contre
10 pour les blancs et
en cas d'égalité en cas de match nul
c'est noir donc saut qui l'emportera
donc donc voilà
Nakamura qui a l'obligation de gagner la
partie
dont il est pas terrible je sais pas
comment on a fait c'est pas mal mais il
en a perdu beaucoup hein quand même un
magasin saut ceux qui dit qu'il a
beaucoup de mal à
passer de des parties lentes aux parties
Blitz il arrive pas
il est en l'an et tout et il lance sa
bulle et d'un coup il faut accélérer
tout changer il y a beaucoup de mal à
s'adapter au nouveau format
on regarde un peu le début de partie ou
pas
[Musique]
depuis un moment j'aimerais bien y
rester je pense qu'il y a un petit point
un petit demi point
c'est toujours ça et soit la troisième
place qui je pense va aussi faire le
podium
je pense qu'en fait il est possible que
le tournoi soit gagné pour lui peu
importe ce qui se passe demain
si
le seul qui prendra
mais s'il gagne
c'est un magasin je pense quasi fini
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'il perde
demain sa partie lente et que Naka gagne
la partie vente et que bref et la 4
t'inquiète pas qu'il va sécuriser la nul
pour être deuxième que lui il va se
poser pour être premier enfin bref c'est
zéro quoi
la jauge qui a complètement pété un
câble et puis on prend alors pourquoi
est-ce que alors attends j'ai un peu
tricher avant à 5 cigales et pourquoi ça
gagne ah oui il y avait des problèmes
et des 7 des 5 peut-être ou ah oui des
cinq
il y a tout qui il y a tout en l'air ah
c'est hyper compliqué là c'est la tour
bouge par exemple je cavalais prendre
j'ai ça j'ai découvertes bref c'est fini
donc là il y a eu E3 obligé pour pour
justifier dame 1 et c'est d'un problème
je pense dans la partie
et après ça te défaite et ben écoute
Fatou je crois que on va regarder après
le classement
il rend la pièce quoi il donne la pièce
prise peut-être des cinq ou Star Wars
des 5 va être joué je pense pas tout en
des 5 prises tout reprendre cavalier
prend et je prends la et au revoir
une pièce de plus
c'est une pièce de plus après je peux
aussi manger trois c'est quatre avec un
clouage il faut calculer sur ta route
calculer quand tu gagnes normalement non
[Musique]
ça a été joué
elle te reprend cavaler prend le 5 et je
pense que ça va te donner au prochain
coup là
après
[Musique]
c'est une pièce nette de moins je fais
ça je fais ça je vais vraiment vraiment
pas comment est-ce que tu peux tenir je
pense qu'il va abandonner maintenant il
y a pas jouer un coup de plus OK
qui est juste perdu et
malheureusement je n'ai pas de stats
d'Armageddon mais je pense que soit
l'Armageddon il a perdu énormément de
parties
en fait j'ai pas le souvenir de le voir
gagner un Armageddon
c'est marrant
tu as un chien
pas tout
alors
et bon bah il y a un pion qui avance
mais je vais le bloquer regardez déjà
cavaler contrôle la Casey je vais
changer une pièce là enfin à deux on
contrôle la case B2
ça se passe bien quand même ça se passe
bien pour les blancs
pas du tout comment les Noirs pourraient
gagner mais les Noirs jouent un peu par
dépit parce que ben c'est du bled c'est
du chaos donc il peut toujours
se passe quelque chose mais bon en vrai
il y a très très peu de chance moi je
trouve qu'elle avait les B2 je suis
dames et Dame des trois ma souris voilà
moi je ferai un truc comme ça pour
essayer de de m'enlever du vis-à-vis et
de changer les tours et en plus mon
cavalier il est bien là il empêche la
pousse et du pion moi je croyais B2
celui de dames
et je prendrai pas la tête il a fait ça
on va sûrement voir cavaler B2
OK
le roi un peu faible
c'est pas le moment de
de craquer là
est-ce qu'il a pas raté un dame
c'était cool
pour bloquer ce serait pour moi ça
serait le plus facile
mais est-ce que ce qui va se passer
mais c'est vrai que là attention
changer les tours peut-être mais pour
moi c'est prendre c'est prendre un
risque
échec là
[Musique]
peut-être que je peux
c'est toi qui joue
il a mangé aussi
non d'ailleurs il a raison parce qu'au
final bah écoute ça forcait les choses
d'apprendre je fais juste dame là ou
quoi de enfin
l'occasion d'échanger tu as une pièce en
plus mais c'est comme ça
il a réussi à gagner le pion je pense
échec échec un truc comme ça il va
réussir à manger le pion puis on
et en tout cas c'est un bon essai de la
part de soi parce que moi il a mangé des
pions et puis elle reste plus beaucoup
de pions chez les Blancs si jamais
carvana il se trompe il arrive pas bien
à terminer la partie ecoute il mange H2
il pourra venir en E5 etc
et
[Musique]
c'est pas simple tu vois sur c'est un
blitz enfin là maintenant Bullet c'est
une minute trente contre deux minutes je
passais plein de choses encore
à ce niveau il joue jusqu'au bout il
essaye de créer de danger des menaces
c'est bien faites pareil dans votre
partie
on n'est pas mort tant que c'est pas
fini
donc
attends je peux pas aller ici je peux
manger là au pire des cas peut-être
échec échec sens c'était le plus simple
comment je préfère Fatou manger le
pionbet
à moins que tu manges le Pione mais tu
sais que tu as trouvé un moyen de
récupérer lui quasiment forcé
tu vas manger
tu vas manger tout quasiment tous les
pions sur un chèque
et là ça va être fini ça forcer je crois
échec il sait qu'il a au moins d'un bien
échec il va tout manger en fait
je pense qu'il a ramener la dame tu vois
il fallait la obliger
pour pas prendre enfin perdre sur
l'échec quoi que tu vas aller là là tu
perds sur la chèque donc tu vas venir
ici
sur ça je te fais l'échec si tu montes
je te fais chèque changer d'âme et mon
cavalier va venir empêcher le plus en
avancer donc ça et chaque voilà je vais
avancer en fait puis à un moment donné
je pense que tu pourras plus échapper
aux différents
[Musique]
échanges alors s'il est là
si je viens là j'ai cavalier échec
peut-être je crois c'est 6 alors roi
tu viens là je te fais échec tu viens là
là je prends et je te tu vois en fait ça
va ça finir par là
ça va finir par un échange de dames
tu fais comme ça bon il a fait d'autres
sens
j'aurais fait dans mes chèques en fait
quelques secondes
il va recommencer je pense la même
tactique qu'il a fait avant
il y a 4 secondes chez soi plus de temps
et échec ça va être abandon sur voilà
j'enfilade et sur voilà j'ai enfilade
qui gagne son embargon donc au
classement qui qui grignote encore les
points qui lui manquent pour gagner le
tournoi et
alors qu'on va voir
gooche ici
qui a quasiment enfin qui va gagner sa
partie gauche qui fait qu'il faut aussi
un bon tournoi pour un très solide pour
sa part et s'il y a la partie la partie
classique Google qui peut peut-être
dépasser ça aurait en général et venir
faire un petit podium à toi on ira voir
après ce qui se passe
alors
E4 fou 2 car elle est des 5 tours c'est
un cavalier B4 c'est 7 OK
donc bah écoute mais puis on avance j'ai
à trois qui menacé cavaliers
ici je pense à tous cette position elle
est presque abandonnable fous des quatre
il essaie de mettre
comment je fais pour passer deux pions
quoi c'est ouf quand même
j'ai deux pions passés
c'est de l'art j'ai 7 pions passés les
Noirs ont 7 pions et des blancs passés
liés protégé c'est ouf
en vrai c'est pas possible
comment c'est possible
grâce au PUISSANCE 3
et puis ça passe
et grâce à ce cavalier au début
c'est le je crois que lui c'est le plus
E2 non
Nakamura il se bat pour la nuit encore
il se bat pour la nul et je pense qu'il
va l'avoir sa nul il vient toujours pas
ce qu'on fait c'est il ne vient plus une
fois déjà c'est bien et je sais pas si
il reviendra
se confesser derrière mais en tout cas
pour l'instant
[Musique]
pour l'instant il vient pas
mais oui ici
c'est une position où les blancs pas
grand chose à faire C4 n'est pas
possible parce que je contrôle trop de
fois la case
et donc ça c'est une rupture qu'on
pourrait éventuellement avoir l'autre
cure elle est là je contrôle aussi trop
de fois
et ce puret sur blanc peut-être que si
vraiment tu vas trop loin un jour je
pourrais essayer de le manger et les
Noirs ils ont une position juste où il
faut attendre
donc non je pense que ça va faire un nul
très bientôt
je pense que ça va faire très bien
français mais je sais pas si c'est trop
risqué
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça
ok si tu rentres peut-être que ouais
[Musique]
je peux aussi rentrer attention
attention qui sera le plus dangereux
on arrive à le faire parler à taper sur
assiette
donc je peux presque faire ça en fait
malheureusement pour toi ça marche pas
non mais ok ok ça c'est peut-être une
manière de jouer qui peut être
impossible mais ça donne du gel
adversaire
mais là juste peut-être je sais pas
est-ce que si je fais roi G7 3G 8 est-ce
que tu peux progresser également
si tu rentres qu'est-ce que tu fais
je sais pas
tu as pas de pousser de pion possible
t'avance pas ouais tu as ramener ton
doigt jusqu'à là-bas je sais pas
mais bon j'ai du mal à y croire
parce que tu commences à bouger
je pense que c'est c'est
pas grand chose là non je pense juste
ici que que
[Musique]
il va juste peut-être faire ça ça ou
attendre
ça ça change un peu des pions mais ok
bon ça va être égal les blancs poussent
un tout petit peu mais il n'y a pas
vraiment vraiment de danger ici dans la
position et Google
c'est une position tellement
hors du commun enfin tout ça waouh jolie
je crois que c'est un coup qui va
peut-être forcer l'abandon
[Musique]
après faut prendre mes cinq
puis on prend il va faire quoi il va
faire ça
d'accord
sûrement
là je mange tout tes pions
tu manges madame en fait il va faire une
dame
et contre la pièce tu as plein de pièces
de moi
tu as une tour
d'affilée brillant
waouh c'est joli
ette de plus avec ce pion qui est encore
hyper fort j'ai tourné un
Fatou c'est juste c'est juste perdu
franchement super partie de vous cache
c'était monstrueux
ben ouais je me suis dit bon peut-être
qu'avec avec avec stem de Londres
peut-être que
des fois c'est un peu plus difficile
d'obtenir un avantage avec ce type
d'ouverture après des fois c'est que
c'est des ouvertures aussi qui sont
moins utilisés et surtout à haut niveau
en fait et tu
tout simplement tu
tu penses pas qu'à ce niveau là ça peut
être chaud pour gagner quoi en fait
c'est un peu sous-estimé je pense à haut
niveau
et c'est pour ça que je j'avais du mal à
peut-être tu vois
en vrai je pense que c'est ouf
là il a fait une partie monstrueuse
qu'on avait partagé
on avait joué en équipe ensemble en Top
il est très très gentil
il est extrêmement fort quand même vous
avez vous savez qu'il y a à peine
d'avoir 17 ans
bougie
juste avant le chocolat quoi genre un
jour ou deux avant le début du tournoi
donc il est vraiment hyper jeune quoi
17 ans 2700 je crois qu'on est là
virtuellement je peux vous dire comment
me fait beaucoup parler
et c'est les licornes Carcen
pour pas gagner
encore nul mais enfin gagner
l'Armageddon tout de même il a 27 40 ça
va être 39,9 virtuellement sans compter
la partie qui va gagner maintenant et en
gagnant cette partie là il va gagner
enfin tout je pense environ trois points
donc il va être à 27
43 à peu près et 27 43
et ben il dépasse pas mal de monde il
dépasse un VL il dépasse à rognan il
dépasse pas
et il serait à la 13e place 13e place
mondiale quoi c'est ouf
à seulement à seulement 11 points
derrière le numéro 1 de son pays
qui est numéro 9 mondial un fichier
amende
qui est une légende en un logiciel une
grande légende les joueurs Indiens ont
un immense respect pour pour Vichy
salut les gars
salut michivios
oui boy il y a des gens c'est vrai que
comme Google il y a des gens qui
qui font un peu plus vieux
c'est plus vieux mais on l'a vu dans
on voit que c'est un petit jeune mais
après
on voit qu'il est enfin il fait plus
vieux aussi
les jeunes de 17 ans sont pas forcément
le costard la chemise tu vois il est
bien habillé parce que il faut quand
même dans un endroit hyper prestigieux
c'est normal etc et après aussi c'est
vrai que bon à 17 ans il a une belle
table aussi bah écoute après ça c'est la
vie si vous voulez mais c'est vrai que
mais il est il est hyper impressionnant
chez Canon c'est juste ouf quoi
puis en vrai c'est différent ouais
encore une fois quand tu lui parles bah
tu vois qu'il est jeune quoi ça c'est
clair moi je dis moi je l'ai vu en
équipe
oui il avait 13 ans
en Top 12 il avait 25 50 à 13 ans pas
souvent des comptes quoi
et bon voilà tous les soirs il passait
toutes ces soirées un jour ping-pong
quoi comme un fou je peux me prendre
trop content c'est un enfant quoi c'est
un enfant et par contre quand tu parlais
de lui et chaque
il a il parlait pas qu'un enfant de 13
ans quoi genre il est hyper mature et il
de grande connaissance enfin c'était
c'est vraiment c'est ouf moi je suis un
énorme respect pour lequel c'est ouf
très content qui qui
enfin de le voir
au plus haut niveau en tout cas ça me
fait hyper plaisir et c'est pas fini ce
n'est que le début
refasse tous
[Musique]
et Google en plus Google
c'est comme Prague aussi c'est la même
c'est plutôt le sud
[Musique]
moi je suis à l'avocat
je suis allé chez Nike
je suis à la chaîne et j'ai rencontré
là-bas
pragamanda ainsi que ramèche ainsi que
tout le monde
[Musique]
on a une petite nulle de signer entre
Abdou et
bon c'était
c'était
arrivé encore une fois on l'avait on
avait pronostiqué donc bientôt je vais
recevoir l'heure de début de
l'Armageddon de joueurs
[Musique]
je sais plus qui était dans le chat qui
m'avait dit qu'on pourrait faire à 4 et
G5 pour ouvrir les cases blanches et ben
c'était en train de se passer là toi
c'est très possible c'était lui regarde
en train de se passer
tourco prend B2 faux et F1 tourbé si ça
part en bon coup H4 a été joué
5 fois je crois présent et ouais il est
là tour dedans qui garde les tours c'est
normal de garder les pièces quand même
au final j'ai une qualité de moi et j'ai
5 de jouer
alors que se passe-t-il pas tous si on
fait cavaler prend E4
20h55 leur magasin
mais
[Musique]
c'est quoi de l'ordre
je l'ai pas contente quand je fais ça un
petit peu
si on pouvait bouger le fou on serait
content
es enfin tout
je ne sais pas il faut chercher
ton D7
effectivement ça a l'air pas mal ton
dessert dans ma vie
comment je termine ah mais je prends un
sac
nous aussi et tourner
merci vraiment que toi tu es là
heureusement que vous êtes là les gars
je commence à avoir des idées de tour
des sets comme viens de nous trouver
enfin vienne de nous trouver Michy VIOS
et Chris
attention
alors on a la vidéo sur google change
vous changer ça je vais mettre la 2
et
d'un point de 4 fois tout qu'est-ce
qu'on joue ici
j'arrive pas à sortir de mon fou en
semaine
aurait pu être pas mal quand même
et là j'arrive pas à le faire
tu as trouvé un truc
ça c'est un gros problème je peux pas
jouer ça ni ça j'aimerais bien pouvoir
le faire malheureusement
pour débute d'abord on
salut tout salut Fatou pas mal de noir
ayant gagné
dans l'Armageddon salut politique
il avait déjà fait ça dans la foi je
l'avais montré que non et là encore
aujourd'hui c'est car voilà qui a gagné
on va voir bientôt
dans 10 minutes on va voir la partie de
de Abdou avec les Blancs contre Naka
pour Star magasin
parce que
8 alors je comprends mais le problème
c'est que je suis toujours pourri ça
change pas ça change pas
essayer de faire ça
mais sinon oui ça aurait pu être cool à
un moment donné
à un moment donné on veut on veut se
déclouer pour sortir de là
mais écoute matériellement les Noirs ont
quand même une qualité et un plan de
plus
mais le roi
il y a ça en l'air ça en l'air une
découverte là qui peut arriver
franchement faire attention la vie rien
qui est pas l'abri de de
tactique enfin tu vois
4 sur foulard mais déjà il y a la tour
en prison
il a pas
bougé ça si le fou bouge il est
peut-être tu reprends un F7 mais je
pense à ça tout
et sur ça peut-être qu'il faut le faire
tourner
ah c'est ça l'idée
le cavalier et si le cavalier bouge j'ai
cavalé des 6 échec et ramasse la tour
extrêmement compliqué et si je bouge le
fou ben écoute
après je peux aussi manger ça mais j'ai
plein de ça peut-être que faut faire
attention quand même à pas trop trop
parler de mes pièces
mais peut-être que sur ça je crois j'ai
deux
fois
c'est là-dessus qu'il a joué
et puis un petit peu il a bien joué
contre ce fou
à quel coup pour information pour savoir
quand est-ce qu'il va y avoir le
quatrième
avant de recevoir un incrément qui est
franchement
seulement 10 secondes c'est c'est pas
grand chose 10 secondes
et ouais seulement 10 secondes
ton prof est fin oui tu peux mais tu en
fait je pense que si tu rends la qualité
c'est peut-être le coup d'ailleurs je
sais pas du tout mais et ben j'aurai les
compensations gratuites parce que
j'aurais récupéré le matériel j'ai
encore ça en prison
moi j'ai des bonnes pièces au final j'ai
enfin passé
je pense que tu as quand même certains
problèmes à gérer avec les Noirs malgré
le fait que tu me rendes la qualité mais
peut-être que ça peut se soulager
peut-être que c'est le mieux à faire
dans tous les cas si tu veux le faire
moi je te conseille d'attendre que les
blancs des clous pour venir manger toi
tu gagnes un temps
parce que faut vite par exemple les
blancs vont probablement faire manger de
easy
et sur Orange dès maintenant bah c'est
peut-être le moment de manger
plutôt que ça plutôt de faire de suite
je pense
ça me paraît toute la plus logique
ça me paraît plus logique
je sais pas si
sur ça il y avait ça qui me posait
problème les deux pièces
je sais pas si c'est bien ou pas
aucune idée
ok mais dans le doute
[Musique]
je préfère
donc voilà ok donc tour des 7 mets ton
point fort on va prendre fin baby
Tourcoing F7
et les noms ont-ils diminué pour la
qualité rendu bah déjà tu es pas mieux
en fait tu es jamais mieux
je pense qu'il y a là tu as quand même
une position assez
sur voilà il faut quand même trouver un
coup
je peux pas faire ça
mais là avec les noirs
et j'ai un peu passé aussi t'attends ton
fou pourri
en fait à trop de problèmes là tu m'as
rendu matériel mais tu as encore des
problèmes donc moi j'ai envie de te dire
j'ai une qualité j'ai une qualité à un
pion de plus je suis prêt à te rendre le
matériel
pour qu'il y a rien quoi alors pour
faire nulle par exemple pourquoi pas
mais là je rends le matériel
pour me retrouver encore un problème
ça m'a pas tu vois ça me va pas je
trouve que c'est pas faire
il est dangereux il
peut le danser c'est juste une pièce
à d'autres problèmes pas de problème
avec des pièces blanches qui s'activent
en cavalier une tour qui qui sont plus
dangereux
plus que 5 minutes à la pendule un peu
moins de 5 minutes
plus que 5 minutes
pour jouer encore
six coups
six coups chez Guiri il y a pas de
rajout de temps je vous rappelle que
l'on rajoute tant il va être posé
seulement à partir du 40e coup donc
c'est extrêmement
on peut voir la fin si vous voulez
pouvoir la fin de Google qui me fait
plaisir une belle partie
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait une belle partie
ou pas
combien de coups brillants
qui va gagner la partie si tu prends je
fais dames ouais mais c'était vraiment
une
masterclass de la part de Google cette
partie franchement un grand bravo à lui
avec il ne reste que cette partie là à
l'IRESA contre Guiri et dans 6 minutes
Fatou on va avoir aussi l'Armageddon de
Naka contre Abdou
je vais vous mettre la partie de la
c'était de Google
en fait un coup brillant sur tfcom c'est
quand tu sacrifies une pièce et que
c'est fort et que c'est joli ça c'est un
sacrifié
après je fais ça quoi
[Musique]
mais ça fait peur quand même
ça fait un peu peur j'ai rien je crois
tenté à la place de thoracis
[Musique]
il est très généreux aujourd'hui je sais
pas ce qui lui arrive mais il est très
généreux aujourd'hui là pour lui donner
ses pièces
j'ai besoin de générosité
bienvenue sur cette chaîne surprenante
à Brest c'était à Brest le Top 12 quand
je suis allé
j'étais je suis encore dans l'équipe de
Cannes et Cannes Brest c'est un petit
peu l'opposé
c'est à l'extérieur
ils ont encore six coups à faire en 5
minutes
est-ce qu'on va pas choper FC
peut-être que c'est une galerie comme ça
échec
si je veux faire nul j'ai ça je pense au
pire des cas ah mais je suis cloué
tu reprends un F7 roi G6
et C4
et on échange assez bien
joyeux anniversaire
vous savez qu'à côté d'ailleurs il y a
un centre commercial
docteur carwana
centre commercial c'est pas une blague
on veut la photo enfin je sais pas si
c'est comme ça ou si c'est le
nom de la de la rue mais je crois qu'il
est sur le docteur Carvin
commercial pas loin de chez moi
et d'ailleurs il y avait un tournoi
d'échec là-bas
et il y a encore un le 18 juin je n'irai
pas
et non peut-être ami à ce moment-là
donc malheureusement c'est dommage que
c'est quand même chez moi c'est à 5
minutes à pied
on va avoir la nul je pense il joue
comme toi encore une fois toujours
écouter tout toujours m'écouter si vous
voulez essayer d'être fort d'échec
alors là regarde Fatou est-ce qu'on va
avoir guéri c'est un joueur qui fait
beaucoup de nuls mais c'est vrai que
c'est qu'un genre aussi qui essaye
beaucoup de fois et
mais là je pense qu'il va se rendre
compte que il y a ça en l'air c'est trop
compliqué il y a jack note ah il a pris
à trois waouh alors ça par contre je
m'attendais pas moi je pensais à tout
reprendre les trois attends prends F1 et
ça m'a Valère d'être
et après il a commencé à faire un tourbé
4 enfin un truc bizarre et là il a
commencé à perdre des pédales
apparemment le seul coup c'est fou c'est
4 ah mais c'est chaud encore cette
partie hein
il peut tout se passer encore cette
partie
je sais pas oublier l'Armageddon mais
est-ce que tu veux qu'on voit
l'Armageddon on se retrouve cette partie
cette partie elle est plus
serré
mieux de rester ici après le chat a le
droit de dire l'inverse
je suis un peu de loin et je regarde et
puis si jamais un truc marrant je te
dirai mais je pense c'est bien de
c'est pas mal de regarder filou en plus
on a quand même pour fille ou de base on
va essayer quand même de rester un petit
peu le titre du stream oui oui mais
après ça dépend
pas grand chose donc on a le temps de
partir un petit peu à côté mais là c'est
la fin de partie c'est le gros
designotes et les deux rois sont
presque mat
et la jauge dit que c'est quoi qui égale
alors là du coup là faut plus écouter
plus que trois coups à jouer pour avoir
un incrément mais c'est un incrément de
seulement 10 secondes parcours c'est pas
grand chose
rien du tout ça permet juste d'arrêter
de noter mais déjà arrêter de noter je
sais pas si note encore on les voit à la
caméra
on a pas la belle vue du dessus c'est
dommage il y a que la table une ça c'est
vraiment dommage en plus ça finit ça
finit express
cette partie je suis assez déçu
donc la plus qu'une minute 45 Giri
ouais c'est compliqué là c'est complexe
franchement si je devais choisir une
couleur je prendrai les blancs tous les
jours enfin tu vois
avec les noirs
donc on va aller où là je crois qu'il
faut aller là
si je vais là je parle cavale d'accord
si je vais là tout F5 qui va pouvoir
manger le cavalier il va ici il s'auto
clou
qui sont au clous mais ce retour là il
se passe quoi
enfin
et là j'ai plus assez de pièces pour te
mater la Tour Eiffel rien à
et attends c'est chaud ça
j'ai eu peur
point d'interrogation échec cavalier
devant forcer je prends là et c'est
hyper chaud encore
comment tu t'appelles ça ça
c'est extrêmement extrêmement chose hein
Fatou
fourchette mais je sais pas ce qui est
le mieux
il y avait la prise je pense que E4 va
être joué
pour empêcher fous là
prend échec et comprends tout
incroyable filou qui va qui risque de
batranus
il y a un incrément maintenant il y a un
incrément deux de 10 secondes par coup
et surtout des cas j'ai même du foulard
en fait
en fait tu vas tu vas tu vas perdre ta
pièce quoi incroyable tomber de
en trois j'imagine
en fait tu peux pas bouger quoi tu es
complètement pattes quoi tu es pas de
partout
et en plus même si tu G6 dans l'idée de
vouloir tu vois et ben le cavaler des
fonds de fou en fait c'est horrible tout
se défend quoi
tout se défend
voilà
c'est quoi la défense
[Musique]
la jauge n'aime pas ça 3 G4 était le
coup 6 fois tout qui empêchait bon il y
avait chacun le fou et si je prends
plein vers ton B4 peut-être que roi j'ai
4 était le coup
et empêcher tous les échecs ça ça va
donc après c'est compliqué les joueurs
ont tellement peu de temps la pendule
faire des erreurs à ce niveau là c'est
complètement normal
roi descends sur ton
plutôt aller ici pour l'instant là-haut
mais je sais pas encore comment je peux
me défendre peut-être qu'il y a le
stress
mais même en pratique c'est trop dur
quoi trouver 7
ah il veut réussir à faire geste un jour
il est fondre comme ça un plateau
peut-être c'est
le truc alors
ça paraît quand même une blague ça me
paraît trop trop dur
je suis cavalier là qui font regarder il
y a plein de choses à regarder
où il est blanc c'est plus facile je
prends les blancs c'est clair
allez 20 secondes chacun avec 10
secondes d'incrément dommage qu'on n'est
pas
les grands écrans quoi
qu'on puisse pas vous montrer la partie
depuis la caméra en haut comme avec ma
gus
qui avait laissé 6
pourquoi j'ai 6 et qui est possible ça a
été joué
coup logique le roi H6 apparemment il y
a c'est un raté
c'est pas pourquoi
attends là une laisse le la tour en
prise et l'idée c'est que sur tout
reprend il y a tour des tours je pense
sur ça il y a ça waouh c'est monstrueuse
ce qui nous trouve avec si peu de temps
à la pendule les joueurs sont sont
monstrueux quoi c'est monstrueux ce
qu'ils font Fatou
non mais c'est pas joli quoi
il arrive à sortir de ce clouage et tout
à quelques secondes de
j'allais dire de la fin mais avec
seulement quelques secondes de rajout
ils arrivent à s'en sortir et puis
maintenant que le cavalier est sorti
c'est pas simple
tu es perdu
ça reste compliqué en pratique c'est
hyper dur pour le noir j'ai des pièces
qui sont pas du tout coordonnées j'ai un
mauvais fou il y a des réseaux de maths
de partout j'ai encore tout échec fou
échec il a de partout
j'ai pas de fourchette là qui traîne
c'est un truc bizarre quoi il y a pas un
truc qui traîne
c'est un truc de fou
mais ils sont sortis de des problèmes
j'ai pas vu les coups mais j'ai vu que
on comprend comprendre on n'a pas le
temps de comprendre quoi exactement
ça va très vite
et puis en plus pour le noir
mais bon après c'est un Pione plus qu'il
y a pas trop signification
quand même des chances de nul tout le
temps
ou le 5 cavaler prend il va juste manger
et faire reprend et ça va faire
nul pas tout ça va faire nul donc quand
même je pense que tu reprends la faire
avec fupron bah il peut toujours essayer
plus tard d'aller manger les pions et de
jouer tour fou contre tour
et ça ton retour et ben
[Musique]
et ben c'est nulle théorique mais en
pratique avec peu de temps la pendule
oui c'est une enfant qui appelle maman
je vais fermer la voilà je vais faire
mon bébé
c'est parce qu'ils ont 10 secondes
d'incrément par coup donc à chaque coup
qui joue il regagne 10 secondes
on peut aller voir rapidement
c'est parti elle va soit elle fait nul
direct soit
on va manger les pions et ça va jouer
encore à une demi-heure
donc on peut regarder si tu veux
rapidement je vous laisse la caméra des
joueurs on va la retaper en accélérer il
y a eu 20 coups
et
ouais c'est normal
quelque chose
et ils ont refait la même ouverture à
peu près
donc c'est une bonne ouverture pour les
Noirs dans ces positions de dans ces
positions de
Armageddon c'est les positions quand
même qui sont très solides pour les
noirs
la caméra qui tricote un petit peu avec
ses pièces
c'est extrêmement solide pour les noirs
mais les blancs qui au fur et à mesure
avance avance
ou ps5 attaque la tour on se replace sur
les cases noires
ou pas c'était pas un bon coup
apparemment d'un F4
ok il y a abandon sur le champ pourquoi
avons-nous sur le champ tout
est-ce que j'ai pas un trou à 5 juste
[Musique]
je crois c'est perdu ben écoute belle
démonstration en tout cas de Fiero on va
enfin passer dans la partie des filles
pour voir la fin
dernière partie
objectif c'est pour fion c'est de
réussir à gagner les deux pions s'il
arrive à gagner les deux pions et ben il
va avoir droit à 50 coups
pour
pour gagner contre guéri
d'ailleurs 50 coups est-ce que tu
connais la règle Fatou
les différents façons de faire nul ou la
règle des 50 coups
sans prise de pièces ni avance attends
ni avancer le pion
et
c'est tout après
[Musique]
il faut un arbitre pour pour témoigner
oui mais bon là il y a plusieurs
arbitres là oui eux ils sont bien
entourés nous on tournoi si on veut
juste que 50 coups on a un peu plus de
problèmes on n'a pas forcément quoique
la dernière partie donc logiquement tu
as un arbitre qui te surveille
après la règle précise c'est que si
pendant 50 coups il y a pas eu de prise
ni de mouvement pion et ben tu peux
réclamer la nulle voilà
mais pour ça il faut savoir que les
joueurs n'ont plus les coups donc c'est
difficile de compter
et donc en fait la règle c'est que tu as
50 cours voilà mais si tu réclames pas
la rabbé qui peut pas te mettre nul par
contre ce qui est assez nouveau depuis
quelques années et bien c'est que
maintenant l'arbitre peut déclarer nul
après 70 coups sans prise ni mouvante
donc l'arbitre en fait là on est sûr que
si jamais allé résa arrive à manger les
deux pions
et ben on sait que le paramètres ils
vont déclarer nul après ce sont des
coups
mais
et
qui soit à côté oui mais l'arbitre
et ben
il a mangé le dernier pion donc
maintenant s'il arrive jusqu'au bas du
coup à 80 + 70 tu vois cela arrive
jusqu'au 150e coup
et ben c'est nul
voilà et si Guy réclame avant
après ça
fera du coup c'est compliqué parce que
tu vois il tricote bien mais il faudrait
qu'il arrive à mettre son four en
en C4 pour pouvoir manger là c'est
jamais facile parce que dès qu'il met
le foulard
ouais
il va essayer de mettre le fou ici ou
peut-être ça et ça
je sais pas s'il va réussir à la gagner
enfin en tout cas à manger des pions
mais vous inquiétez pas normalement
si jamais les pions sont mangés c'est
quand même nul mais c'est une huile qui
est en pratique pas si facile à tenir
bon pour ces joueurs là qui ont 2772
c'est normalement classique ils doivent
savoir comment comment défendre et ils
doivent réussir à le faire avec peu de
temps il y a toujours une marge d'erreur
qu'on peut avoir on a vu des des super
super grands maîtres perdre c'est parti
encore ça peut arriver
en tout cas moi je considère que tu
joues cette position au contraire 2500
je pense que tu as quand même avec peu
de temps la pendule tu as un pourcentage
intéressant de gain je pense
moi je passerai
tous les jours pour
enfin tu as nul et tu sais que
j'ai envie de dire tu peux pas la perdre
mais je connais un grand maître français
qui a perdu cette finale avec les Blancs
je connais un travail français qui a
perdu tout il a perdu tout
fou mais il avait le Torfou et
tu l'as entendu
je crois que j'étais
dans les paroles non je pense pas
c'était ça fait très très longtemps que
je le sais enfin ça fait vraiment très
longtemps je pense que tu
as peut-être pas la même alors mais tu
parles de qui
je réfléchis je te dirai après
il y a un grand maître français que je
connais très très bien d'ailleurs que le
salut d'ailleurs s'il m'écoute
il avait tout fou et avec Torfou bah
écoute parce que il a une chance de
gagner il peut pas perdre quoi
et il a perdu la tour
et après il avait il avait le fou contre
la tour et tour contre vous c'est nul
encore sauf qu'il était pas dans le bon
coin donc là il y a une règle etc et en
fait il a fait que la fenêtre il a perdu
quoi enfin il a perdu enfin il a perdu
deux fois la fenêtre de fou quoi et
gagner avec une tour pour de fou c'est
extraordinaire quand même
et le pire c'est que c'est que ce grand
maître j'ai rien contre lui dans un
rapide
il y a quelques années maintenant et
j'ai perdu contre lui avec ma tour donc
on s'en fout il m'a battu la même finale
et quand il m'a battu puis franchement
vas-y quoi
je savais pas
combien de coups on avait fait tu sais
je prépare avec laver en fait parce que
50 coups comment tu veux c'est une
partie parce que là eux ici ils peuvent
réclamer parce qu'ils ont c'est parti
qui sont supervisés parce que tout est
en ligne sur internet mais moi quand je
jouais c'était une salle random tu sais
tu avais personne qui suivait tu as pas
l'arbitre qui marquait les coups tu
avais pas transmis on savait pas combien
de coup ça faisait donc moi je peux
faire ce que je veux en fait mais et du
coup moi je savais pas qu'il fallait que
j'appelle l'arbitre pour qu'ils mettent
les coups
c'est en rapide tu es en train de partir
tu penses quoi
du tout et c'est pour ça que c'est un
petit peu je suis trop trop un petit peu
bête
tu peux avoir la nuit facilement et non
en fait tu sais que tu vas tu sais que
tu en fait moi quand j'avais eu cette
position je me suis dit je vais la
perdre parce qu'il peut laver pendant 10
ans quoi à un moment donné personne va
apprendre des coups quoi enfin tu sais
et bon ben j'ai défendu pendant
longtemps mais j'ai fini par croquer
mais en plus tu as pas de temps c'était
dur à le temps mais j'avais plus de
faire la pendule
bon là je sais pas si c'est moyen de de
gagner le pion
on va aller prendre
donc après voilà tu es obligé de
manger là je pense en fait
je pense qu'il faut il faut manger
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui savent pas
comment ça marche ça fait nul
pour ceux qui ne seraient pas comment ça
marche
et ben
si jamais par hasard j'oublie et qui
fait dame
et ben roi fou contre-atto c'est nul
très facilement à condition de réussir à
mettre son fou dans le coin inverse de
sa couleur ça veut dire que là j'ai un
foodcasse blanche donc il faut que
j'arrive à mettre pas mon fou mon roi
pardon ici ou ici si j'arrive à mettre
mon roi dans un de ces coins là c'est
nul très facile pourquoi je vous montre
un donc je vais faire exprès en flou
laisse-moi aller là-hauts pour que je
vous montre un peu voilà en ce moment
s'il te plaît voilà et en fait pourquoi
est-ce que c'est nul je joue la faire
facile parce qu'en fait tout simplement
je vais me rends en coin et le fou à
côté
et maintenant en fait et ben il y a trop
de il y a trop de
pâtes si je monte mon roi je bouge mon
fou
sur échec je mets le foulard menace pâte
si tu attends je bouge mon roi et moi je
vais faire ça je vais attendre et mon
fou il va toujours repartir revenir
cette position allait complètement un
gagnable ça ok
un gagnable
alors que si vous mettez
si vous mettez
si vous mettez la tour enfin le roi
pardon dans l'autre coin genre moi je
comprends rien je vais là-bas avec mon
roi
laisse-moi dans le coin s'il te plaît
hop voilà et ensuite tu montes ton roi
je mets mon fou à côté
cette finale et ben elle va être perdue
parce que en fait il y a plein de maths
mais la différence tout à l'heure c'est
que mon fou était ici enfin mon roi
était là et mon fouet à côté vous voyez
là il y a un espace entre les deux dire
que maintenant et ben en fait il y a pas
de pattes il y a un exemple qui se fait
mon Roi peut bouger et si il bouge je
matte donc là je vais attendre et le roi
de doigt bouger le fou éclouer et je
matte alors que si le fou était ici à la
place d'être en C8 c'est un B8 ce serait
nul parce qu'il y a un patch possible et
j'ai pas le temps en fait d'attendre
avec ma tour donc il y a pas de pattes
et il y a pas de de voilà ces exemples
simplement
donc voilà pour cette fin de partie mais
du coup là il y a eu ton projet d'eux
parce que j'ai un commencé à être une
grosse menace ton projet d'eux est nul
signé parce que tout s'échange donc en
tout cas une belle partie en tout cas de
la part de
deliresa et Annie spectacle tous les
biens franchement c'est assez simple
hein
et comme tu dis du spectacle de la
surprise donc c'est ce qu'on aime
c'est ça donc on va avoir un arnaque et
donc quand même entre ces deux joueurs
on va voir 300 encore
je vais attendre qu'on me qu'on me tient
au courant alors en plus ce qui est bien
c'est que j'ai plein plein enfin tout
d'interview à vous montrer donc on va
pouvoir juste avant de les montrer le
temps que tu étais les charges
route si personne ne dit rien on peut
pas réclamer la nul au final par exemple
75 coups jouets et tu tombes autant si
tu tombes autant
si tu tombes autant attention tu perds à
moins que l'autre n'est plus rien sur
l'échiquier à part son roi on va dire
certaines conditions mais sinon non bah
faut quelqu'un il faut que soit tu étais
noté les coups les 50 coups soit qu'il y
a un arbitre qui puisse qu'il puisse
valider ta réclamation
[Musique]
en norvégien
je vais je vais télécharger des trucs là
si vous voulez hop et là
donc
ça m'intéresse un peu moins de l'écouter
ah ça y est
non j'ai pris le mauvais attendez je
vais j'ai Google qui est intéressant je
pense qu'on va pouvoir ce qui a fait une
partie de monstrueuse
je pense qu'il faut l'avoir celle-là et
je vais Nakamura qu'on peut voir si vous
voulez avoir l'Armageddon
aussi
et
j'ai failli fabule sur la classe aussi
ça va être à quelle heure
21h30 dans 10 minutes je pense qu'on a
le temps de vous mettre les deux les
deux trucs
et on va commencer par Google si tu veux
comment je veux tu veux aller
on vous envoie les petites les petites
interviews des joueurs et puis après on
vous traduit enfin un petit peu un petit
peu tout ça
alors
s'il te plaît
nous expliquer un petit peu alors sa
partie je vous la faire rapidement je
vous remets sa partie si vous voulez je
vous la ramène accéléré
ferme ça et la partie gauche elle est où
je la vois c'est vrai
ah oui
en accélérer il a dit que il a gagné une
partie avec London était content et que
tari ajoute quelque chose qui ne joue
pas d'habitude il n'a pas besoin dans
les détails et il a dit qu'il se sentait
bien tout le temps et sauf que il a raté
le cavalier G4 de de Tariq qu'on va voir
très bientôt le coût arriver voilà il a
raté il sentait qu'il pouvait des
problèmes mais après il est très content
d'avoir la position qu'il a eu qu'il a
obtenu je crois que c'était très
compliqué très intéressant
et méditation qu'il a connu et pour une
fois qu'il est entré là-dedans là c'est
juste c'est juste gagné mais il a fait
une partie je trouve absolument
incroyable en tout cas il est très
humble tu vois c'est un jeune qui qui
joue qui monte et franchement
tu vois il est
resté
juste il est là et il est trop fort quoi
donc franchement ça fait hyper plaisir
de l'avoir
vous avez apprécié la fin de la partie
tour 1 dans ces quatre il a mangé il a
mis le foulao il a mangé le pion en C5
et ça a été abandon alors je vais encore
un autre pour vous montrer alors j'ai
deux choix j'ai Nakamura ou Kawana Fatou
tu préfères qui
on a déjà vu tout à l'heure
alors on est revenu donc voilà ils ont
demandé à
affabi déjà ce qu'il pensait de la
partie de de Abdou contre un contre
Nakamura et il a dit qu'il pense que
c'est juste une nulle et que il sait pas
si Abdou veut faire nul ou pas parce que
c'est vrai que
il avait l'occasion de faire nul
plusieurs fois auparavant dans la partie
mais il le faisait pas et donc vu que
objectivement c'est nul à 99% mais que
peut-être que voilà mais ça va être nul
et après ils l'ont demandé ce qui se
passe il a dit que peut-être que Abdou
voulait aider karwana dans le sens où
s'il battait Nakamura qui est sont
poursuivants directs pour le titre de
champion du Nord watchesse
et Guillaume je pense qu'on s'en fout
mais pour moi je comprends c'est hyper
parce que ça lui permet d'être gagné on
va voir la fin et ils ont parlé du fait
de gagner sur demande parce que c'est
vrai que si là si je vous montre un
petit peu les les
classement West le saut il a été à
11 ans à 17 et demi et karena était à 14
et demi donc ça aurait peut-être pu
rattraper Nakamura et quasiment rattrapé
le voyez et en fait il explique bien que
lui
enfin ils ont l'habitude de ces matchs
là et lui il doit jouer pour la nul pour
sécuriser si vous voulez
son avance et le gain du tournoi et que
il avait plein de parties qui sont
online en raison beaucoup d'expérience
et il sait que s'il faut faire nul et
ben
il sera nul c'est-à-dire demain la Paris
Mans enfin tout ça va être car voilà
contre Nakamura
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il disait ça
il disait que lui il sait que enfin dit
que si jamais demain j'arrive à tenir la
nul contre Nakamura c'est que je mérite
de gagner le tournoi par contre si
j'arrive pas à tenir la nul c'est que je
mérite peut-être pas et du coup je ferai
le deuxième et du coup ça coûte ce qu'il
dit mais il dit bon voilà en fait
formule et puis voilà donc on verra
après connaissant
connaissant n'a qu'à
c'est pas le genre à faire au lit dans
la partie
moi je pense demain d'avoir une partie
assez tranquille de la part des joueurs
mais bon
vraiment faire
comme ça
non lui il est plutôt du genre à gagner
du temps
en plus Carona enfin il faut quand même
dire un Nakamura il a un petit peu hors
du circuit et c'est un joueur qui
travaille plus trop le l'échec même si
par temps noir etc
mais par exemple
car voilà c'est quand même un des
joueurs les mieux préparés du circuit
bon je pense qu'il est juste une partie
voir ce qui se passe mais je pense pas
enfin moi je vois pas du tout ma caméra
aller chercher Caroline
et tu vois les gens qui rejoignent la
même partie exactement sauf que là à
lireza il a joué un coup avec cavalier à
3 qui est assez bizarre qui permet de
gagner la paire de fou
mais bon
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé je dois savoir
merci
ok donc là c'est la dernière partie pour
aujourd'hui donc écoute
je pense que
firou doit pas être si mécontent sa
position
parce que c'est une potion qui joue il a
la paire de fou et là des personnes donc
certes il a deux pions doublés en a
mais là la paire de fou ça c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est un mustwin il
est obligé de gagner pour gagner
l'Armageddon si il fait nul bah il
perdrait la margadon et dans ces format
là tu aimes bien avoir des positions
vivantes ou tu peux faire des choses
donc c'est pas le bon symétrique tu vois
comme italienne comme ils font dans
plein de
[Musique]
de position pour jeux d'échecs
donc dame 1 l'originalité
il tente des choses
[Musique]
que c'est la on va dire un petit peu on
va dire la suivante
la chèvre
100% espagnol là en string pas français
mais des fois je parle plus français
c'est ça
[Musique]
du tournoi en fait tu vois
c'est pas forcément que cette partie là
c'est trop loin en général ça c'est
plein de choses
on va aller voir ce qui s'est passé
quand même
il a joué
j'ai 5 et là tout le monde s'attendait à
cavalier F5 ou cavalier F3 et il a joué
F4 et surprise F5 le foot est enfermé
surprise il fait foutrant ici parce
qu'il menace de manger là en plus de
manger là il y a maintenant les 7 ans
c'est quoi
un coup
[Musique]
et encore
l'ordinateur il considère que c'est
complètement gagnant en fait parce que
le charisme plus fort quoi mais c'était
pas un gain ok je pensais qu'il y avait
un gars de maths un truc comme ça quoi
en fait oui c'est écrasant un niveau
professionnel
moi je fais ça il y a ça c'est horrible
c'est pour ça en fait il mange pas tout
de suite
c'est compliqué une pièce de moi mais je
la mange quand je veux et tu vois que le
roi noir il est quand même assez au
chaud il y a plein plein tactiques qui
peuvent arriver
plein de taxes qui peuvent arriver
plus tellement en danger
peut-être tu reprends le mieux ça me
permet de ça me permet de doubler les
tours plus facilement en fait
pas mal
tu reprends
et là tour aussi moi je te raconte
parce que j'avais envie de m'enlever de
vis-à-vis là et ça me fait peur c'est
que ça ça fait peur aussi
en pratique c'est dur pour les blanches
trouve finalement ton BF2 alors pas mal
aussi j'ai peur de me faire clouer mon
fou en fait licorne je suis pas sûr à
100%
prendre en F comment
calculer mais juste que je sais pas je
trouve que c'est
pas clair
je pense qu'il veut jouer quatre il faut
H3 un truc comme ça
en l'air encore le coup de
le coup de
travailler free bird je crois
H4 il y a eu F6 x 3
x 3 c'est pas un bon coup selon la jauge
peut-être qu'il va se prendre tour j'ai
vite rapidement
jouer sur la sur la colonne h
le caméléon
cavalier qui faisait Royal on a dû
donner la qualité dessus
trois quatre cinq six trois quatre cinq
six mais tellement H5 effectivement
sinon ça passe et là maintenant si on
arrive à activer les fous ça peut
vraiment être fort genre ça ça quoi mais
le problème c'est qu'à chaque fois que
je le fou il y a il y a juste trois là
quoi
après c'est intéressant parce que même
ça Fatou ça parce que je peux pas manger
là
manger là et manger là
je perdrai ici
et une tour
et
ouais mais malheureusement tu perds le
fou à la fin donc là il y a des
problèmes pratiques pour
celle-là mais je crois que ça veut se
perdre en fait
parce que sur ça peut-être la fougère 5
en fait je vois que ça pas tout
ouais mais il faut
G4 au revoir
et je vois pas d'autres coups que fou G5
qui se pose la question
je mange attends je mange là pardon je
mange là tu peux pas manger ici parce
que tu as la tour en prise de force
mais bon tu vois il trouve du jeu quand
même
aller raisin il trouve du jeu c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais trouve du jeu les
créatifs quand même
ça c'est sûr
pour gagner ça c'est c'est
clair et ça se voit dans son style c'est
c'est vraiment très agréable à regarder
en tout cas un joueur comme ça qu'il y a
tellement envie de gagner tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps c'est génial
clair pour nous un spectateur et tout
c'est génial quoi
c'est très beau à voir
quand même j'ai pas envie de donner la
paire de fou fou F5 alors quand même un
coup qu'on se qu'on veut jouer quoi
miroir
sur un truc comme ça
et au final attention parce que je vais
finir par être en prison c'est que mon
four donc j'ai réussi à mettre mon fou
au milieu mais je m'en fous quand même
un jour il va être pris je pense que tu
as pas le choix il va falloir manger des
cèpes
tu as pas le petit barrage avec ton
on va dire fougère
moi je pense à ça
ok ça a l'air possible je crois que ça
sent bon plus quoi
et après bon bah je perdrai jamais quoi
c'est pas possible
je sais pas mais bon
qui commence à perdre le temps qu'il
avait d'avance
oui
qu'est-ce qu'on joue là
en fait
[Musique]
il a une position intéressante mais il
est tout cloué quoi les pièces sont pas
actifs elle est plus que 3 minutes
contre 2 minutes 22 je vous rappelle que
c'est du chaos c'est du chaos 40e coup
on est au 29e là et autre 40e on aura
une seconde de rajout pour les pour les
devoirs
[Musique]
incroyable
autant maintenant
je peux faire ça si je veux peut-être
c'est plus simple
tu peux pas manger
je mange là et là maintenant j'ai un
pion de plus mais tu vas le prendre
quand tu veux et là tu vas jamais gagner
alors à la trique non je suis pas sûr
parce qu'en fait alors c'était enfin si
tu veux faire un débat avec politikon
animal Proust je t'envoie directement
vers lui
ce qui nous a déjà fait un débat l'autre
jour mais moi je pense pas que ce soit
gros avantage enfin tant en
c'est clair que les blancs doivent
absolument gagner mais tu commences avec
3 minutes d'avance à la pendule
et les blancs donc tu as un avantage de
la couleur et l'avantage du temps les
noirs peuvent jouer pour deux résultats
et c'est vrai que les blancs dans ces
parties là ont tendance à faire souvent
oline c'est qui est normal parce que il
a gagné donc ils perdent aussi beaucoup
parler sur le chéquier parce qu'ils
prennent beaucoup de risques donc c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué et
en vrai c'est pas si clair d'ailleurs
dans les vrais les vrais Armageddon
souvent c'est un tirage au sort et le
joueur qui gagne qui râle au sort peut
choisir si les blancs ou les noirs et
très souvent dans un magasin les joueurs
je croyais que c'était blanc en fait
souvent on avait eu lors de lors du
tournoi cheesekid il y a pas longtemps
sur Jess come fr on avait accueilli on a
eu la chance d'accueillir
Jules Moussard sur la chaîne et il a eu
plusieurs Armageddon il a tout le temps
pris les blancs et il avait expliqué
lors de la drague donc
alors pourquoi prenez les blancs parce
que Ben
le match en fait il y avait que des
gains gains il a dit bah dans la
stratégie de match enfin si je prends
les noirs pour faire un nul alors
qu'avec alors quand j'ai les Noirs
exploser à chaque fois et ben moi je
prends les je prends les je prends les
blancs et je joue pour gagner
et voilà courage c'est très joli très
joli
abandon de la part de byza alors les
raisins il est complètement craqué mais
la position était juste intenable dame
de gars il faut prendre set surprise là
alors là c'est hyper compliqué la
position apparemment on dit à 5000 mais
je t'explique moi comment ça fait nul
enfin j'ai une pièce de j'ai une tour de
moi quoi c'est pas compliqué pardon
c'est nul mais bon en pratique c'est un
c'est impossible quoi tu vois
impossible et
donc du coup sur ça il y a eu ça prise
mais bon en pratique c'est un calcul à
la fin tu es d'accord c'est trop
compliqué
il y a eu ça pour nous en tout cas et
pour lui visiblement c'est pas c'est pas
évident non plus
trois quatre minutes pour rien trouver
je vois ça quoi ça montre qu'il a pas
trouvé la suite et c'est extrêmement
difficile là pour comprendre
quand tu vois cette position en fait
juste bah tu calcules pas la suite tu
dis bah non j'ai perdu enfin tu vois
apparemment ça fait nul mais c'est juste
ouf quoi
bref donc donc firou qui a fini par
perdre cette armage et donc alors on va
rencontrer un petit peu bon les
résultats on peut les voir rapidement
merci beaucoup à chess le pancraft pour
pour le raid merci bienvenue à vous yes
bienvenue à vous alors regardez là on a
un média Rohff qui a perdu leur magasin
contre Magnus Ali resa qui a perdu leur
magasin contre Aniche
Ikao qui a perdu aussi l'Armageddon
contre Abdou et gooche qui était le seul
à gagner sa partie classique contre
Ariane tari et Fabiana kawala qui a
continué son lead
en gagnant un et demi à un contre so
Wesley maintenant
les résultats jusqu'à maintenant vous
avez carvana qui est toujours avec 16
points et vous voyez la seule chance de
carwana de gagner l'événement c'est
qu'il ne perde pas demain en classique
parce que demain il est noir contre
Hikaru si Hikaru gagne avec les blancs
en particulier
et ben il va arriver à 16h30 et coiffer
au poteau
carwana sur a fait tout le tour en tête
et derrière on a sur 13,5
points de cache qui a réussi à remonter
sur la troisième marche du podium
une très belle partie aujourd'hui
Google ça fait longtemps qu'on voit
grimper grimper grimper en élo et tout
et franchement c'est pas par hasard
qu'il est là quoi c'est vraiment très
très talentueux et c'est très cool de
l'avoir ici
on a Annie je guéri et wesleo avec 11 et
demi et on a deux jours aussi à 10
points et demi raisin et Magnus qui font
un tournoi plutôt un peu décevant j'ai
envie de dire tous les deux même
qui est pas en forme non plus avec 7,5
qui fait trois points mais c'est un
petit peu logique enfin tout il était
comme on disait le petit poucet de la
compétition c'est le joueur local qui
qui est invité à participer à
l'événement mais
mais qui est
donc
en dessous de tous les autres c'est ça
c'est ça donc voilà donc pour nous c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui
on va se revoir demain à partir de 17h
pour la dernière ronde Fatou du du
Nord-Ouest
donc attends hop donc voilà merci à tous
en tout cas d'avoir
suivi suivi le stream
et merci beaucoup à toi à tous nous
accompagner
et puis merci à toi merci à tous et à
tous ceux qui participent qui animent le
stream c'est c'est un plaisir pour nous
et puis c'est plus sympa de pouvoir
parler avec des gens et puis donc merci
à tous en tout cas pour tout ça et je
vous dis à demain pour le dernier
épisode de cette série un Norvège et
voilà passe une bonne soirée et à demain
ciao ciao une excellente soirée à tous
au revoir